So Leute wie versprochen ich bin wieder da wobei das hört sich so an als würde ich
das immer machen wenn ich sage ich komm an das stimmt ja überhaupt nicht wenn ich sage wenn
ich sage ich komm abends an was meint ihr zu wieviel prozent der fällen bin ich dann wirklich da
also ich ich tippe mal auf 20 prozent wenn es hochkommt also 20 prozent der fälle wo ich sage
ich bin nachher wieder da bin ich dann auch wirklich da muss man kurz die klimaanlage anmachen viel zu
warm was haben wir denn hier 27 grad gerade drin und ich muss muss mal kurz muss mich mal kurz
muten im obs so hust hust hust aus und was ist denn jetzt los haltet mal so jetzt ok ich weiß
auch nicht irgendwie wackel konnte ich kann es kein wackel kontakt sei nach keine ahnung ist
auch egal moin leute
hat jemand hat jemand games dann quick geguckt die letzte woche
nur interesse halber ich guck schon eine weile nicht mehr zumindest nicht regelmäßig ich
habe diesmal ab und zu reingeguckt so keine ahnung insgesamt vielleicht so eins zwei stunden über
die woche verteilt nicht viel ja ok ja ich gucke ja immer noch viele ich finde ich finde ich muss
euch ehrlich sagen ich weiß ich seit ein paar jahren ist da für mich die luft raus was nicht
mal in den speedruns liegt sondern irgendwie dieses gesamte event strahlt irgendwie für mich so aus
dass es keinen spaß mehr macht aber ich meine da gucke ich mir halt nicht an ich gehe jetzt nicht
auf twitter und flame erstmal rum wie man das heute in der heutigen zeit so macht ich gucke
es halt nicht games dann quick irgendwie ist auf dem rechten ohr als entweder ist mein rechtes ohr
ab und ich höre rechts schlechter als links was ich nicht was ich nicht glaube oder mein mikro
in irgendein teil spielt das falsch ins headset ein funktioniert alles keine ahnung was geht noch
nichts wir gucken uns jetzt stellen an zeigen an weil ich habe euch heute morgen ja erzählt ich
bin aktuell nicht sonderlich happy bei mir auf der arbeit geht hauptsächlich um mein lieblingsthema
nämlich homeoffice wo sie sich jetzt überlegt haben dass das doch nicht doch nicht mehr so
gehen soll und man jetzt 50 prozent seiner zeit wieder ins büro kommen soll und da bin ich überhaupt
nicht scharf drauf doch doch also ich habe zwei sachen schon in wie gesagt aussicht ist zu viel
also ich habe eine sache wo also ich habe eine sache in frankfurt ich muss jetzt überlegen was
ich sag ja eine sache in frankfurt das ist quasi kann ich sagen bei der konkurrenz aber es ist auch
ein größerer finanzdienstleister in frankfurt da kenne ich einen der da arbeitet und dann auch
ein etwas kleinerer laden die komplett am arsch der welt ist aber 100 prozent homeoffice in
irgend so einem kaff aber 100 prozent homeoffice ist in frankfurt ist auch homeoffice teilzeit homeoffice ich
meine was ist ja besser geht es ja nicht mehr ja es ist richtig erzähl mal warum warum das
interessiert mich wirklich warum also mir persönlich wäre es ja ganz ehrlich mir persönlich wäre es am
lieben am liebsten ein tag die woche im büro und der rest homeoffice ich hätte aber auch nix gegen
komplett homeoffice aber ich habe keinen bock auf 50 prozent der zeit die firma so remote shops
arbeitet im letzten jahr also sprich die firma erwartet dass ihr remote arbeitet stellt euch aber
nicht die mittel und wege zur verfügung um ordentlich remote zu arbeiten das ist natürlich
ziemlich pepega von der firma ja wir erwarten die wir erwarten die dann dass das funktioniert
wahrscheinlich gar nicht die denken sich einfach ihr seid doch IT-experten dann macht doch mal
ja wie gesagt also ich hätte kein problem mit einem tag die woche das würde ich machen aber
die firma wo ich aktuell arbeite ist ja der meinung ne das geht nicht 50 prozent wieder ins büro und
ganz ehrlich bahn fahren ich will nicht öfters mit der bahn fahren als nötig das ist der größte
abfakt ins büro gehen an sich ist gar nicht das was mich stört aber das bahn fahren ist das was
mich stört ja übrigens was ich witzig fand ich habe das auf der aber ich habe das ja auch
meinem chef gesagt ich habe gesagt also kann durchaus sein dass ich mich dann umgucke ja und
er meinte ich bin bei weitem nicht der einzige der diese gedanken hekt ja die sind ganz okay die
habe ich auch letztens mir mal angeguckt aber keine ahnung ach da kann man gar nicht reingucken da
kann man gar nicht reingucken ohne und angemeldet zu sein naja wir melden uns nicht an bei uns ist
das noch also bei uns ist es noch nicht so krass tanzer dankeschön für den sub 6 alter 36 monate
weißt du eigentlich dass das drei jahre sind quickmaps 12 plus 12 plus 12 ist 36 der ist
der tanzer ist drei jahre musst du euch mal vorstellen drei jahre auf twitch am start und
ich kann mich gar nicht daran erinnern dass es drei jahre her ist dass ich schon so lange streame
keine ahnung was hältst du von einem fernstudium keine ahnung keine ahnung ich stelle es mir sehr
anstrengend vor schwierig vor weil du alles selbst machen musst du kannst auch schlecht
jemand fragen keine ahnung es ist wahrscheinlich alles eine frage des willens ja ich weiß dass
ich definitiv zu faul für wäre also keine ahnung ich kann nichts zu sagen weiß ich nicht
richtige hypersubscriber leute dankeschön für die ganzen subs ja massive nicht prime nicht
prime moment ja so unterschiedlich können die ansichten sein oder beziehungsweise die
betriebe wo man ist oder oder auch die persönliche einschätzung ja weil er schreibt hier ich finde
bei 100 prozent bei 100 prozent homeoffice geht so viel verlorben dass jetzt wirklich fachliche
themen sind aber auch einfach nicht zu zeigen ganz ehrlich gerade das letzte ist bei mir besser als
vor ort ohne scheiß mit denen wo ich zusammenarbeite ist das deutlich angenehmer und besser über teams
zu kommunizieren als vor ort vorort sind die zum größten teil belagert auf irgendwelchen
meetings wo nicht weiß was ist in teams sobald er auf grün ist kannst du anrufen er geht dran
ich glaube ich habe noch selten so viel von meinen kollegen erfahren also was bei ihnen
gerade so geht persönlich als in der zeit wo wir homeoffice haben ja meistens ist das so man
man hat irgendein thema oder sei es im anschluss von irgendeinem meeting dann sagt es wenn hier
was weiß ich sagst sagt dann irgendeiner ja wie sieht es aus hast du deine heizung umgebaut
das sind so sachen da unterhält man sich noch zehn minuten nach dem meeting mal ein bisschen
drüber ich frage ihn ja und was macht deine was weiß ich was macht deine regengrinne keine ahnung
so dinger und das sind sachen das habe ich quasi nie diese gespräche haben wir vor ort so gut wie
nie geführt ja ja namen lieg ist er nicht so wild samuel tdo master dankeschön leute für die subs
ja beim frasier da hat der friseur noch regelmäßig gestreamt wann hatten der friseur
eigentlich zuletzt gestreamt ei der friseur wo ist er denn nee quatsch heißt er doch gar nicht
ei frisi heißt er twitch wann war er denn zuletzt on irgendwelche web games vor acht
monaten alda kein quait frasier
ich habe gehört hat auch einen neuen job und war zwischenzeitlich unterhosen tattoo
photomodel habe ich mir sagen lassen falls jemand in dresden das kann es durchaus sein
dass der bilder von farben von fabian gesehen hat in unterhose kennt die kennt die jemand hat
jemand falls sie in dresden wohnt habt ihr den zufällig gesehen was hältst du von pap und
mysql oder postgres ql naja ich persönlich das wisst ihr ja ich bin postgres fan mysql mag
vielleicht ein ticken schneller sein dadurch dass die bewusst auf manche features verzichten
dafür hat postgres so viel geiles zeug eingebaut von richtig geilem jason support bis volltext
suche bis trigramm suche postgres ist einfach die beste datenbank es gibt ja pp kann man machen
der vorteil von pp ist dass jeder nur nach 15 billig haus der pp support hat ja so was da
hätte ich das wäre auch vollkommen ok ja der witz ist bei uns ist es anders der betriebsrat
ist da komplett dafür aber die haben irgendwie wieder 180 grad kehrtwende gemacht zu dem was
sie gesagt haben da käme ich mir ein bisschen verarscht vor also nicht der betriebsrat sondern
die management ebene da komme ich mir ein bisschen verarscht vor bei uns erst groß angekündigt so
nach dem motto wir sind jetzt voll moderne home office und dann wieder nicht bei der telekom ist
das ganze übrigens auch relativ agile und und international ich hatte letztens mit einem von
der telekom was zu tun also nicht nicht privat sondern auf der arbeit und der war von telekom
cross border services das hieß so das hört sich erst so ein bisschen an wie illegale einwand rum
oder sowas in der richtung aber nein das ist wirklich wohl ein team bei der telekom cross border
services nennt sich das und die hatten dann insgesamt irgendwie vier leute oder so der eine
kommt aus paris der andere war deutscher in tokyo der andere war aus tschechien der andere war aus
deutschland war wirklich komplett verteilt wenn es der produktivität hilft hilft da sind die
bei mir zu alt auf der arbeit ich bin jetzt nicht der krasse wie aber bei uns außer außer einer der
früher mal da war der gibt es aber schon eine weile nicht mehr er redet da keiner über anime
tja wäre schön wenn das euer abteilung wenn das unser abteilungsleiter auch so sagt
ja das ist das ist blödsinn ich finde auch so gezwungen funktioniert das nicht so was
weiß ich wir machen jetzt gezwungen ist gezwungen eine kaffee pause und dann die macht jeder auch
die webcam an das ist alles blödsinn die leute die gerne miteinander reden machen das auch so
weil wenn leute dabei sind auf die ich keinen bock habe erzähle ich lieber gar nichts und
sagt leute ich arbeite mal weiter also ja da gibt es zig workshops wir hatten auch schon alles
mögliche wobei lego haben wir noch nicht gespielt dann auch schon irgendwelche workshops wobei ich
sagen muss einer dieser workshops aber das kann ich wirklich jetzt kannst du nicht nur an einer
hand abzählen es kannst du an einem finger abzählen weil es genau einer war und das war
kein workshop das war so ein begleitetes projekt also da hatten sie irgendein consulting irgendeine
consulting firma mit super krassen feifett agilen scrum mastern hatten sie engagiert und man durfte
sich drei themen raussuchen und da also man konnte es jetzt war freiwillig ja man konnte sich drei
themen raussuchen und dann ging es darum was man denn in diesem in diesem themenbereich für
verbesserungspotenzial sieht und das dann vor vorstellen das habe ich mitgemacht ich weiß auch
nicht was mich geritten hat warum ich da freiwillig mitgemacht habe aber damit da habe ich da habe ich
damals freiwillig mitgemacht und da hatten sie irgendwelche scrum master leute von einem von
extern consulting firma und ich muss sagen das war gar nicht schlecht die hatten ja sie hatten
wirklich ahnung wie man das am besten macht das hat das hat man auch gemerkt das hat zusammenarbeit
technisch gut funktioniert und auch vor ergebnis technisch war das echt gut ich habe dann am ende
präsentation gehalten mit dem team zusammen wo wir das gemacht haben plus dann noch mal so abschluss
präsentation noch vor ein paar anderen leuten und das kam insgesamt wunderbar an nur was meint ihr
von den übrigens also das war ich muss es vielleicht noch ein bisschen bisschen ausführlicher
erklären so zwei minuten bevor wir uns an die stellende zeit angucken das war so eine das war
so eine maßnahme dass die geschäftsführung sagen kann guck mal wir sind voll agil und verbessern
uns ständig und da ging es darum dass man sich eben verschiedene themen gebiete rauspicken soll und
da dann eben sich überlegt was könnten wir denn verbessern in der firma und das dann vorstellt
da waren dann so sachen dabei wie komplexität oder server land system system landschaft hieß es
komplexität system landschaft zusammenarbeit solche dinger gab es dann da in der richtung und ich
habe ich habe das thema system landschaft genommen weil ich mir gedacht habe als ehemalige linux
heckermann dort in der firma da kann ich da am besten was dazu sagen und ich habe vorgeschlagen
ich habe damals die vorschläge gemacht also was ich gut finden würde ist wenn man ein zentrales
eine zentrale datenbank mit web frontend weil man hat aktuell man hat bei uns irgendwie acht
verschiedene datenbanken befüllt sodass man endlich mal unsere gesamten systeme ordentlich
durchsuchen kann und mein zweiter vorschlag war nachdem wir auf der arbeit so viele abkürzungen
haben leute wir haben abkürzungen die sind doppelt und dreifach besetzt zum was ist für was ist für
euch was ist für euch ads für was steht bei euch die die abkürzung ads aim downside werbung manch
einer wird sagen active directory services das hätte ich jetzt eigentlich eher gedacht dass
irgendwie ja oder so ich hätte es eigentlich gedacht irgendeiner kommt mit kommt mit active
directory aber nein bei uns ist diese abkürzung anders besetzt das ist der auftrags dispatcher
service auftrags dispatcher sender für mich gar nicht ich glaube auftrags dispatcher sender
ist es und und wir haben zig solche abkürzung und deswegen habe ich vorgeschlagen wie wäre es
dann mal mit einem ordentlichen klosar klosar wo jeder was eintragen darf wo halt nur sagen
mal paar leute dafür schon zuständig sein sollten die halt gucken was denn da so grob
eingetragen wird dass nicht da einer reinschreibt pups oder so keine ahnung so und fand ich echt
sinnvoll das einzuführen und es kam auch bei der vorstellung super an ach ja und mein zweiter
vorschlag war man könnte so ganz pleading ad scheiße machen noch einen chatbot an den klosar
attachen dass man dann auch über instant messenger fragen kann ohne dass man die webseite aufmachen
muss so das waren meine drei vorschläge kamen alle super an und was man also ordentliches frontend
für unsere systeme zum durchsuchen einen ordentlichen klosar den alle benutzen und für den instant
messenger weil es moderne ist in chatbot was meint ihr was von diesen vorschlägen gemacht wurde
obwohl man sie super gefeiert hat und gesagt wir verfolgen das weiter ratet mal was wurde
gemacht nix korrekt nichts gar nichts und was meint ihr was wurde umgesetzt was wurde umgesetzt
von allen anderen teams und vorschlägen die da so gekommen sind also es ist jetzt auch sein könnt
ja auch sein dass sie meine vorschläge einfach und die vorschläge von unserem team kacke fanden ja
nix korrekt es wurde nichts es gab insgesamt fünf teams mit glaube ich insgesamt 15 vorschlägen
weil gut fünf teams drei vorschläge mit fünf teams jeweils drei vorschläge 15 sachen und
von diesen 15 sachen wurden ohne scheiß nichts gar nichts umgesetzt es wurde abgefeiert und
auf ja oberer management eben quasi erzählt kurial war geil wie schön agil wir sind hoho sind wir
cool wir verbessern uns steht man hat sich gefeiert man hat nichts umgesetzt also es ging eher um
selbst feiern das ist das was mich bei der firma wo ich arbeite auch ein bisschen nervt wir feiern
uns gerne selbst aber machen eigentlich nix was feierungswürdig wäre und es wurde nix davon
umgesetzt es gab dann noch nachfolgetermine mit einer neuen besetzung die sich drum kümmern
sollten und die haben dann irgendwann frustriert aufgehört weil sich nichts getan hat halt wahnsinn
naja so ist das halt team building event sind immer cringe ja zum glück ist uns das erspart
geblieben ja das verstehe ich auch nicht dass ganz ehrlich das sind wie die manager die alle
meinen sie sind eleon musk und sind noch nicht mal eleon musk auf wish bestellt so möchte
gern eleon musk aber wie gesagt es reicht nicht mal zum eleon musk auf wish bestellt was
das ist kein bock mehr das ist auch eines der gründe warum ich mich so was nicht mehr beteilige
nähe ist nicht passiert ist schon ein bisschen länger her das ist einfach in der in der markt
in der aktentasche verschwunden und man hat nie wieder was von gehört das ist gut das ist gut
weil daran sieht man dass gewisser wille zur veränderung besteht dass das management auch
eingesehen hat man muss vielleicht sich ein bisschen anpassen ja und man sieht dass die
informationsweitergabe funktioniert in beide richtungen das ist auch ganz wichtiger punkt ich
glaube es kennt jeder dass er sich schon gefragt hat warum kommen die informationen nicht richtig
an wieder von oben nach unten noch von unten nach oben das sieht man bei dir aber daran dass das
anscheinend funktioniert also sprich die die die manager kommunizieren das richtig zu euch weiter
was denn da eigentlich gewollt ist und wenn wenn ihr dann was sagt dann wird es auch dementsprechend
wenn sich denn was tut wieder wieder ordnungsgemäß nach oben kommen sie das ist das ist gar nicht
schlecht also das spricht für die firma wo du bist dass das funktioniert
wie ernst ist ist ein neuer job auf das gala von 1 bis 6 5 ich werde auf dauernd 50 prozent
ins büro gehen also ich gucke mir dass die nächsten 1 2 3 wochen vielleicht bis ende
des jahres mal gucken ich meine ich habe dann eh drei monate kündigungsfrist an aber ich
gehe davon aus ich werde bestätigt da drin dass ich keinen bock mehr auf bahnen fahren
habe 5 also wenn der es wirklich so bleibt mit 50 prozent anwesenheit im büro bin ich weg ja
nee das kannst du so nicht sagen das stimmt nicht das stimmt nicht die sind nicht davor
geweiht persönliche persönliche empfindungen über zahlen gute manager interessieren sich
für die zahlen nicht nur für die zahlen aber gute manager interessieren sich für zahlen
nämlich insofern was sind irgendwie messbare und nach vollziehbare ergebnisse das machen
gute manager schlechte manager sind nicht in der lage oder haben keinen bock oder kein was auch
immer diese zahlen sich anzugucken und entscheiden nach gefühl und dann kommt teilweise sehr
merkwürdiges zeug bei raus nicht so schlimm ist das nicht du hast du hast manche firmen die
sind da meine unter manche unternehmen die sind der meinung sie sind hier das nächste google und
wollen dass du erst mal an der tafel den binary tree invertest aber die kleine klitsche um die
ecke will das nicht und die wenigsten firmen in deutschland wenn sich gerade irgendwie sap
microsoft oder sonst was ist hier bei uns werden dich mit sowas nerven ich meine dass du ein
bisschen was erklären sollst das kann ich verstehen ja so gewisse fragen würde ich auch stellen wenn
ich sagen würde ich würde net entwickler einstellen den würde ich auch irgendwie fragen so was was ich
was sind deine lieblingsnougat packages oder was sagst du visual studio oder rider den würde ich
schon themenspezifische sachen ausfragen einfach um raus zu kriegen ob der kerl ahnung hat ja oder
zum beispiel wie würden sie ein neues backend webanwendungsprojekt angehen mit jenem den
vorgaben irgendwie keine ahnung müsste ich mir wenn ich sowas wirklich interviewen müsste da
würde ich mir vorher gedanken machen aber ich würde ich würde den schon dinger fragen um
raus zu bekommen ob er ahnung hat ich würde den nicht den binary tree inverten lassen einer tafel
aber ich würde den schon ein bisschen ausfragen ob der ahnung hat ne das mache ich nicht das
würde ich auch nicht einsehen ich brauche mir doch nicht kostenlos was für die und dann sagen
sie so nach dem motto ach nee dann dreisten wir uns mit ihnen zu reden es kann doch auch sein dass
du beim ersten gespräch feststellst diesen kacke zu den willst du gar nicht also mal so initiales
gespräch sollte stattfinden ohne dass sie irgendwie was großartiges von dir wollen ja solange deine
skills passen zu dem was sie suchen und das erst mal so aussehen als könnte das passen dann
sollte es ein gewerbungsgespräch geben und dann noch eine zweite runde ist ja okay und da kann
man dann auch ein bisschen mehr machen aber hier machen die linden sie erstmal diese aufgabe damit
wir überhaupt ihre bewerbung durchlesen das kannst du wie gesagt das kannst du als microsoft machen
aber nicht als programm programmierbude um die ecke welcher ist der main in overwatch ja das
würde ich aber jetzt vielleicht programmierern der neu ist und dort nicht programmieren soll
nicht fragen hätte ich jetzt würde ich in den e-sport manager suchen keine ahnung dann vielleicht
auf der anderen seite wenn er mir erzählt er spielt gerne overwatch dann würde ich ihn fragen und
dann würde ich erst mal sagen dass ich total enttäuscht bin was blizzard mit overwatch gemacht
hat und wenn er mir dann zustimmt dann wieder eingestellt kommt auf den laden an kommt auf den
laden an so also wo sind wir hier stehen geblieben also heise und golem jobs sind eher für die
memes ja vor allem ist die heise seite deutlich zu hell diese gucke ich diese seiten gucke ich
mir meistens nur an weil dort die lustigsten stellenanzeigen sind für videos die ernst zu
nehmen den stellenanzeigen eher weniger zumal diese plattform glaube ich ja auch nur aggregieren die
werden gefüttert von irgendwelchen anderen plattformen glaube ich weiß ich nicht glaube ich
ich würde nur noch teilzeit arbeiten teilzeit und mit hohem home office anteil
dafür müssten sie weniger bezahlen und ich mache in vier tagen das was vielleicht manche
in fünf machen also insofern soll sie sich noch freuen btf ich würde mich im leben nicht acht
stunden testen ich würde im leben kann doch kein acht stunden test machen nur dass danach vielleicht
sich jemand mit mir zu reden ich bin mir selbst noch nicht so ganz sicher welche seiten alle
alle was taugen also wie gesagt link in profil bin ich mir gerade am einrichten ich muss gucken
wie ich das alles so formuliere dass man möglichst wenig zusammenhang findet weil ich weiß die
leute suchen dann direkt danach was kennt ihr denn chat ich frage euch frage ich euch jetzt mal was
kennt ihr denn für gute stellenanzeigen sein für it jobs also auf sing ist es halt so ich kenne
es von manchen kollegen sobald du dann ein profil hast wo das passt ja stepstone kenne ich ja
dann wirst du laufen von irgendwelchen personalverschacherung typen angeschrieben
meter jobs
ok chat weil ihr das seid das ist meter jobs die seite sieht aus von 1985 monka es ja sing
profil mache ich mir nicht ganz ehrlich link in ist das ding deutschland hängt ein bisschen
hinterher mit sing profilen aber mal ganz im ehr sing profilen mach ich nicht outdated overrated
never donated entertainment neighbor wifi stone laptop das gucke ich mir nicht an ich
mache mir den link in profil und gut
ernsthaft naja dass es weniger leute benutzen
ja die halte kenne ich die kenne ich aber es gibt so ein paar sachen ich möchte eigentlich
weder zur bahn noch zur telekom noch wirklich zu bau davon vom standort her wird sich das
irgendwo sogar anbieten aber das sind so drei unternehmen da habe ich persönlich nicht so
wahnsinnig bock drauf die bahn angucken ich gehe nicht so leute leute ich kann nicht zur
bahn ja überlegt euch mal wenn ich zur bahn wenn ich zur bahn gehen würde ich kann doch
nicht bei der bahn arbeiten und auf und auf twitter schreiben ihr ihr scheiß ich schreibe
muss man überlegen was ich schreibe da teilweise schon ich schlage ja dann teilweise schon etwas
über die über die strenge auf twitter ja wie ich die bahn an anflame also ich kann
ich ich kann ich auf der ich kann ich bei der bahn arbeiten und dann auf twitter und
dann auf twitter schreiben ihr dreckigen scheiß ficker von das glaube ich geht in kombination
nicht ja gut bei der bahn musst du zwangsweise homeoffice arbeiten weil sonst kommst du ja
nie gescheit an und dann sind sie selbst daran schuld zählt eigentlich bei der bahn als
entschuldigung die bahn war zu spät die gucken sich glaube ich ihre bewerber schon vorher
die bahn hat überhaupt keine karriere deutsche bahn ok nur just for fun leute ich will nicht
zur bahn ich will nicht zur bahn wir gucken nur mal wir gucken nur mal sag mal ist das
normal dass schüler heute aussehen wie 25 oder ist das einfach ein schlecht gewählte
stockfoto also stu die studentin sieht deutlich jünger aus als die schülerin oder ist das
die gleiche wait a minute ist das die nee oder das ist nicht die gleiche oder das ist
nicht die gleiche aber so vom typ her ähnlich ich meine die hat aber auch hier ne guck mal
die hat links den ring die hat rechts den ring ananas gut was muss man jetzt nicht weiter
analysieren ja man weiß welchen geschmack der webdesigner hatte genau so also dein einstieg
menschen bei der db ok auch guck mal sind die glücklich alle dass sie da arbeiten dürfen
so happy leute bei der bahn ja ach die sind alle so glücklich dass sie da arbeiten dürfen
jetzt glaube ich sofort er ok job angebote gucken wir mal also nicht was typ bedeuten
soll da geht es nicht um männer so sekunde wo sind wir hier gelandet ok kann man das
irgendwie kann man das irgendwie filtern bundesländer alberta andra bradesch ich wusste nicht dass
andra bradesch ein bundesland ist aber ok bangkok what the fuck ok keine ahnung was
doch immer länder irgendwas deutschsprachiges ok wir schauen jetzt einfach mal arbeitsbereiche
was was haben wir denn also zu bieten informatik ok gibt's vielleicht gibt's noch mehr in
der richtung marketing und kommunikation im leben nicht recht sehfracht soll ok aktualisieren
wie viele seiten drei das gar nicht so viel das kann man relativ schnell durch scrollen
so lange es kein endlos scroll ist also unsinnig ei projekt manager und ich baue und sie infar
structure consultant praktikum ex experte full stack development schwerpunkt backend
das ist was für mich zum beispiel experte life cycle management it program it architekt
mit hands on mentalität für vertriebsohne oje oje oje ein asia enthusiast da bin ich
mal gespannt was er da schreiben ein tablau tablö wie zum teufel spricht man das überhaupt
auf ich weiß gar nicht was das ist tablo tablö o nons tablo tablo das ist doch bestimmt
das ist doch bestimmt was französisches das ist doch garantiert ist es ist es nichts
französisches was ich kann es nicht auch tablo was wie muss ich meine zunge bewegen
dafür überhaupt tablö tablö tablö ich kann es nicht tablö tablö tablö tablö
mitarbeiter störfall management it vor fallerfassung das klingt wie gegentlich eingedeutscht aber
auch nix was ich machen will das ist die gebeten seite die hat endlos scroll guck mal
schon wieder der asia enthusiast aber auch gerade schon 875 kann man das irgendwie kann
es irgendwie besser filtern heilzeit ok sind schon mal weniger städte eigentlich ist es
egal warum kann man nicht nach homeoffice filtern
wie man nach frankfurt 317 remote ja ich weiß aber nicht wo man remote auswählen kann wo
du willst ein wo du willst job alles klar ein wo du willst job ok also gucken wir uns das
erste mal an die haben die ganzes ganze stock stock foto album von ihr gekauft oder also
der fob sind cd entwicklung mwd die folgende karte wird von einem drittanbieter zur verfügung
gestellt aha da sind die ja gut die sind in nähe vom hauptbahnhof das klingt so logisch
für die bahn wenn es darum geht zukünftig millionenfahrgästen 1000 züge auch digital
auf den weg zu bringen braucht es die besten bla bla bla bla bla bla so mit deinem expertenwissen
für automatisierung und der fobs unterstützt du uns bei der weiterentwicklung der fahnen
ci cd pipeline lösung auf git lab base da habe ich sogar ahnung von ich habe eine ganze
weile sogar bei uns die git lab sachen administriert da kenne ich mich sogar aus mit du bringst
dich strategisch konzeptionell architektonisch und entwicklungstechnisch in die themen deines
selbst gemanagten zentral meint was wait a minute ich soll teamleiter machen da steht
da aber nicht alter was soll denn diese dummen anzeigen immer jetzt mal ernsthaft warum schreiben
die in titel das unten drunter ist es was ganz was anderes so hier steht auch hier steht
auch eindeutig ok im team ok du bringst in die themen deines selbst gemanagten zentralen
entwicklung also sprich deines selbst gemanagte das heißt ich manage das oder wie oder wie
oder was oder meinen sie das team ist selbst gemanagte es gibt kein teamleiter das ist
aber ziemlich blöd geschrieben oder ich bin das team ich bin das team weil ich alleine
bin ok das ist ein bisschen missverständlich geschrieben aber das ergibt so mehr sinn
es soll so agil dabei schreiben hat zwar damit nicht direkt was zu tun aber agil wirkt
immer gut heutzutage im team betreibst du die weiterentwicklung wartung der module der
ccd pipeline lösung und fokussiert sich aber auf alle arten von quality assurance und testing
sowie die integration dafür notwendigen tools auf docker und kubernetes basis es wäre das
kann ja alles bedeuten also manchmal wäre gut wenn sie den namen von irgendwelchen tools
tropfen ich meine das container geschichten was mit docker und kubernetes zu tun hat da
kann man sich das kann man sich denken weil kubernetes ist so ziemlich das einzige was
sich durchgesetzt hat was als orchestrierung skalierung durchgeben docker ist eigentlich
das was jeder zum zum entwickeln und container bauen verwendet also dass das aber wäre tatsächlich
relativ interessant was sie genau machen du evaluierst und integrierst potenzielle neue
tools und technologien in die pipeline lösung auch schwer zu sagen als ansprechpartner und
experte für der fachst du die technische fragen rund um die geschaffene lösung erzeugst
du die übergreifende synergie blablabla ja ich mache den kram seit 14 jahren sollte
reichen du hast mehrjährige entwicklung in der projektarbeit unter verwendung von agilen
vorgehend modellen sowie der fortlauf der entwicklung im betrieb von soviel also das
kann ich jetzt schon sagen ich verfüge ich verfüge nicht über eine zertifizierung nach
ist qb ich weiß nicht mal was ist hat das was mit eitel zu tun international software
testing qualifik im leben nicht im leben nicht kritik das im leben werde ich die zertifizierung
nicht machen so du bringst fundierte kennennisse auf der tool basierend automatisieren darf
damit kenne ich mich tatsächlich aus und weiß mit begriffen wie docker kubernetes helm oder
terraform etwas anzufangen ich muss sagen ja ich weiß mit allen was anzufangen terraform
habe ich auch schon paar sachen gemacht aber docker kenne ich mich auch ziemlich gut aus
kubernetes geht so ich bin einfach nicht täglich an an kubernetes sachen dran ich mein kannst
ich alles können dass wir jeden tag ein bisschen besser wenn ja das ist bei der bahn auch notwendig
ich schaue einfach nur weil die weil der chat mich gefragt hat das würde es aber auf das
profil gar nicht auf mein profil gar nicht mal so schlecht passen da fehlt mir eindeutig
da muss da muss noch das buzzword infrastructure es code getroppt werden da steht da vergleichweise
ausbildung gut ist die wären blöd wenn die wirklich darauf bestehen würden ich mein
was soll ich sagen ich mache den kram seit 14 jahren und davon fast fast zehn jahre was
genau in dieser richtung also wir haben wir haben schon continuous integration gemacht
und geht verwendet und daraus automatisch sachen gebaut da hat es noch nicht mal einen
namen gehabt ich habe mir das mit ausgedacht bei uns wie man das am besten machen könnte
gut ich mein nachdem das gemacht hat zu der damaligen zeit haben wir auch einigen blödsinn
gebaut aber man lernt ja draus die sache ist plus die ich kann nicht zur bahn ich kann
nicht auf der bahn ich kann nicht auf dörter schreiben bahn ihr dreckigen kackficker und
dann bei der bahn anfangen das funktioniert nicht spätestens wenn die meine tweets lesen
funktioniert das nicht also ist qb keine ahnung du bist in der lage im dialog mit anderen
teams und projekten praktikable problemen lösungsansätze mit der pipeline alter das
hat die personalabteilung geschrieben diesen satz das ist ja was mehr um den heißen brei
rum reden bitte wenn das die personalabteilung gar nicht weiß was mit pipeline lösung gemeint
ist ich kann auch nur raten weil ich keine ahnung habe wie die das bei der bahn machen
also die schreiben das so hin als wäre es vollkommen klar wenn dort pipeline lösung
steht dass man sofort weiß die pipeline lösung selbstverständlich also ich versuche euch
mal zu erklären was damit wahrscheinlich gemeint ist beziehungsweise höchstwahrscheinlich
so genau weiß man das bei der bahn nicht da ist schlicht und ergreifend gemeint wie arbeiten
die tools die also wie sage ich das jetzt am besten wie arbeiten die verschiedenen tools
zusammen so dass von wahrscheinlich einem commit in einem repo am ende irgendwas rauskommt
was eventuell dann irgendwo automatisiert hin deploy wird ich kann ja nur raten ich
weiß nicht was die bahn damit was sie da genau macht ja also mit pipeline ist in der regel
gemeint die gesamte kette aus tools von ja von punkt a zu oder von start zu ziel in der
regel ist es halt so was wie in commit oder den change in der software zu es läuft dann
live das muss nicht alles immer so in einem schritt sein und das muss auch bei weitem
nicht wirklich vom commit zum deployment sein das kann durchaus verschiedene zwischenschritte
geben so nach dem motto erster schritt ist einer macht commit auf dann machst du automatische
checks ob es den coding guidelines entspricht dann machst du einen automatischen check ob
der ordentlich rebased hat das ob sein branche passt dann machst du einen automatisierten
merge dann machst du den automatisierten test run und danach kann auch erstmal schluss sein
danach kann auch erstmal schluss sein danach kann auch sein dass es ok es muss jetzt erstmal
über irgendwie in den change board oder so also nicht dass dann direkt deployed wird
die leute die super krass modern und agil sind die commiten merchen testen deployen das
dann alle so in einem schritt die deployen auch gefühlt irgendwie fünf mal am tag aber
das machen die wenigsten der regel sind mehrere sind eigentlich sind es mehrere pipelines
die man dann so vielleicht als eine sehen könnte um mit über bauen über testen bis
zum deployment ja und halt noch alle möglichen anderen schritte die dazu nötig notwendig
sind das unterscheidet sich ja von unternehmen zu unternehmen immer ein bisschen was sie
noch alles machen wollen ja der eine braucht unbedingt eine offizielle change runde wo
sowas drin geht der andere braucht irgendwie einen extra change workflow der andere braucht
rar deployment nur im vieraugen prinzip was äußerst agil ist im vieraugen prinzip aber
gibt es ja unterschiedliche implementierung das ist das ganze also deswegen nur weil
da einer sagt die pipeline lösung ist das überhaupt nicht klar was damit gemeint ist
was los also ganz ehrlich das passt gar nicht mal schlecht das passt gar nicht mal schlecht
auf das was ich kann und auch das was ich machen will aber ich habe keinen bock auf
die bahn ich sag's euch ich sag's euch ganz ehrlich es ist auch es sind auch keine wirklichen
diese technik diese technologien kennst du oder so ich bin die bahn kannst du nicht
verbessern das muss von oben passieren äschelenthusiast näh ich hab mir nur just for fun aufgemacht
also liste kann man hier noch text tun suchen wir doch mal was gleich suchen wir doch mal
linux suchen wir doch mal nach linux ein wo du willst job mit linux ok senior lasst uns
performance tester für die ziel nein nein nein leitung administrat ich will keine leitung
machen alle ich will einfach technik krams machen will das machen womit ich mich auskenne
abschlussarbeit im asso das ist die bahn macht viel aws ja das habe ich auch schon
gelesen it specialist operations ok was machen die da full stack ja und monka es alter full
stack java entwickler das das hatten wir glaube ich gerade schon expert it operate admin und
immerhin gibt's wird das noch gesucht ja system system administrator linux mit neugier auf
oracle web logic server da bin ich mir nicht so sicher ob ich da neugierig drauf bin da
steht oracle drin monka ist oracle ja
all a bike flinkster
ganz ehrlich ich sollte nicht ich sollte nicht so viel bei der bahn gucken ich will
auch bei der bahn eh nix machen wir machen jetzt gucken wir schnell das was ich was ich
hier schon offen habe operations linux was was was was was wollen die denn linux technisch
haben nur mal so ohje ich sehe da schon was ganz schlimmes
schlecht ganz schlechte idee ohje ohje ohje ganz bestimmt nicht please monka es
einmal im monat vor ort naja da könnte ich noch mit leben
ich habe von aws halt wenig ahnung ja und was wollen die jetzt davon ich meine da steht
doch nichts über linux drinne da steht da steht aws linux das ist ja mal nichts sagend
du hast gute kenntnisse der administration von linux ja könnte man so sagen habe ich
tatsächlich aber der rest ist ja nur danke für den sub fatal
iot projekte was ist denn das iot projekte kenne ich aber was sind denn iot projekte
industrial internet of things ah das ist doch mal noch mal advanced
es wäre cool wenn die ein bisschen was von ihrer technik reinschreiben würden dass man
halt sagen kann man hat plan davon oder nicht
naja kenne ich mich aus kenne ich mich aus kommt halt auf gut aws kenne ich mich nicht
aus die bahn macht viel aws aber das kriegt man ja auch relativ schnell hin das könnte
man so sagen wie gesagt ich mache linux sachen seit 14 jahren professionell also das sollte
reichen als erfahrung haben das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht hier das ding aber ich will
nicht zur bahn ich mache jetzt die bahn zu weißt du halt immer irgendwelche fragen wolltest
du dich irgendwo als nein wollte ich nicht quatsch jetzt jetzt jetzt sage ich danke
für den sub ne ne jetzt aber ich mache mal die andere nur schnell zu expert it operations
das thema ministrator also was machen die db analytics
er gut neugier auf oracle oh gott da habe ich keine neugier darauf wirklich nicht also
wenn ich auf irgendwas nicht neugierig bin dann oracle soll stack das habe ich ja ewig
nicht mehr gehört das war mal so eine konkurrenz zu puppet und ansible soll stack habe ich
ewig nicht mehr ich wusste gar nicht dass das leute noch verwenden cloud watch habe
ich auch noch nie verwendet ist das das von aws ah genau wie gesagt ich hab mit aws noch
nie großartig was gemacht mit azure kenne ich mich ganz gut aus ich kenne mich sogar
aus mit ein bisschen zumindest mit google cloud sachen aber aws habe ich keine ahnung
von was haben sie da unten da stand noch mal technisch ein bisschen was weil ich weiß
ja heißen ja ja war kotz nein ok komm jetzt suchen wir was was wo ich mich auch wirklich
bewerben würde weil auf die bahn habe ich habe ich echt kein kein bock findest du dass
die doko von azure auch kompletter müll ist naja das ist so typische microsoft doko es
gibt fünf seiten die so aussehen als beschäftigen sie sich mit dem thema moment also gibt bei
microsoft immer fünf seiten die so aussehen als beschäftigen sie sich mit dem thema wozu
du was wissen willst es ist dann aber meistens nur eine seite relevant und selbst die ist
bisschen an dem vorbei was du wissen willst ja also er hat und generell die ganzen microsoft
sachen haben meistens relativ viel doko aber viel am thema vorbei mal mal was positives
zu c++ leute die cute doku ist gar nicht schlecht wer in der misslichen lage ist c++ sachen machen
zu müssen kannst du mal ein bisschen erklären was back end deff ob software entwickler und
so weiter genau ist ja also software entwickler ist das was man sich vorstellt jemand das
software entwickelt man könnte man könnte sagen dass es einer der programmiert aber
sich auch gedanken darüber macht wie man das ganze am besten programmieren könnte ohne
alles direkt in sein editor rein zu hauen einer software entwickelt software entwickelt ist
nicht 99 prozent programmieren sondern ich würde sagen software entwickeln ist 60 prozent
überlegen nee schwachsinn 60 prozent googeln 30 prozent überlegen 10 prozent programmieren
aber das ist halt einer der software entwickelt ich weiß nicht was ich da großartig erklären
sollte so back end ist das was du auf server meistens verwendest also nicht das was du
in einem browser siehst sondern das wo die daten herkommen die die webseiten anzeigen
in deinem browser muss dich unbedingt back end muss nicht mal unbedingt ein back end
sein für webseiten das ist bloß so das was die meisten leute mit back end in verbindung
bringen ja es kann auch sein dass es irgendeine interne linux anwendung ist die pdf abrechnung
generiert oder was auch immer das ist halt das es ist das back end was nicht front end
ist und der fobs ist wenn man eigentlich mal linux admin war und sich jetzt cooler nennen
will da nennt man sich der fobs da geht es hauptsächlich darum man muss schon sagen
da gibt es schon gewisse unterschiede aber viele kommen eben aus der linux ecke oder
aus gibt auch genug leute aus da genug leute aus der aus der windows aus der windows ecke
aber man muss sagen es natürlich schon was anderes als reine system administration da
geht es eher darum dass du dich um entwickler tools kümmerst beziehungsweise so ein bisschen
übergreifend zwischen eben klassische administration und entwicklung ja zum beispiel das was wir
uns am anfang angeguckt haben automatisches testen continuous integration delivery versionsverwaltung
tools und sonst was das ist was das findet man recht oft in so einem bereich hier ist
was für eine bank im rhein-main-gebiet kann ich das kann ich das öffnen chat ist das
ist der link safe der sieht so cheap aus der link ne der link geht noch nicht mal der link
funktioniert nicht da komme ich auf einer übersicht seite raus der link der link funktioniert
nicht guck mal
glow upgrade wann moment mal gucken warum braucht er warum braucht er was zum anlehnen
auf dem klo die idee finde ich aber schon mal nicht schlecht wie wäre das für dich
weiß ich nicht muss ich aufmachen mal gucken also chat welche welche stelle meinst du
die erste stellenanzeige oder wer hat das denn wer hat das eben gepostet mit dem der
eine du weißt schon hat das gepostet so welche davon denn die stellanzeige meinte ich die
obere die obere oder was das da das da
ane das da ok sekunde kann ich dir sagen ob das ok es ist schon mal finanzdienstleister
finanzdienstleister ist lustig weil finanzdienstleister stehen drauf wenn man schon mal bei einem
finanzdienstleister gearbeitet hat ich weiß auch nicht was es so ist in diesem bereich
aber ich kenne das von uns die stehen unglaublich drauf wenn die leute schon erfahrung im finanzdienstleister
sektor haben warum weiß ich nicht ich meine für leute die linux die linux sachen administrieren
zum beispiel ist es ziemlich egal hast du auf deinem klo firmware updates installiert
nee mein klo ist ein bisschen zu alt für sowas das hat auch keine gescheite schnittstelle
um sachen abfragen zu können also check 24 hat eine bank gegründet das ist schön für
check 24 eine neue dimension im mobile banking das hört sich aber schon mal richtig sick
hätt ich an erlebe die dynamik des fintech space mit agilen prozessen kurzen entscheidungswing
einer deilen entwicklungskurve in einem großartigen team das ist so das ist so ein ding das kann
das kann mega nice sein das kann aber auch komplett ein fall sein das ist schwierig jetzt
einzuschätzen zeig mal her was was wollen die denn ich glaube nicht dass irgendwo großartig
alt die leute entlassen werden aktuell ja ok doch so in einem start-up was pleite geht
oder irgendwelche kleinen klitschen die was raushauen und das nicht ankommt ja da immer
aber wäre ich mir gar nicht mal so sicher du hast eine schöne gefunden leute ich ich
guck mir das alles an ist schön dass ihr da euch mit gedanken macht aber so schnell bin
ich nicht also zeigt mal her feife chat ja aufbau optimierung skalierung und weiterentwicklung
der gesamte infrastruktur der gesamte architektur in einem sehr abwechslungsreich ok das heißt
du machst alles oder sicherstellen und einhalten höchster sicherheitsstandards backup und
monitoring strategien ok wie sieht es mit homeoffice aus steht nichts dazu drinnen
mal gucken ob da noch ein bisschen mehr drin steht erste berufserfahrung alter ich mach
den kram seit 14 nun stimmt gar nicht seit 15 ich sag mal seit 14 seit 14 jahren alter
ausbau der deployment prozesse bambou und jenkins in englischer software verwaltung einrichten
rollout server virtuell für sich mit entzettel ok ist interessant entzettel ist nice gesamtverantwortung
des IT-systems what the fuck what the fuck alter du bist linux-systemadministrator mann
moment ist das eine stellenanzeige wo du meinst die wäre gut für mich oder die
wäre gut für ein video geeignet homeoffice ist zwei mal die wochen mit zu wenig außenwillig
in teilzeit arbeiten erste kenntnisse ihr die schreiben das so wie jemand der neu ist
die wollen wahrscheinlich nicht so viel bezahlen das muss gar nicht schlecht sein leute das
kann durchaus cool sein das kann durchaus nice sein ganz im ernst das kann durchaus
nice sein das kommt darauf an was die genau machen und es ist sicherlich auch mal cool
es ist sicherlich auch mal cool ganz normal einfach nur technik machen zu können den
ganzen tag ohne sich mit irgendwelchem oldschool eingerostetem banken kram auseinandersetzen
zu müssen warum schaust du dich eigentlich nach was neuem um weil bei mir wo ich wo ich
aktuell arbeite sie jetzt auf die idee kommen die leute sollen wieder 50 prozent ins büro
kommen und da habe ich keinen bock drauf nicht wegen dem büro sondern wegen bahn fahren
hauptsächlich gut 50 prozent sind bei mir zwei tage die woche aber das will ich trotzdem
nicht sicherheit eines etablierten online unternehmens mit startup flair es gibt zwei
sachen die funktionieren nicht zusammen ich weiß das schreiben viele aber es funktioniert
nicht startup zu sein und oldschool das ist eigentlich dann eher meist da sind dann eigentlich
eher unternehmen die es aber die die keine regelungen haben und internz ein auf startup
machen aber eigentlich dafür schon zu groß sind würdest du dich auf einen tag vor ort
einlassen ja ein tag vor ort ist ok also mir persönlich wäre sogar am liebsten ein tag
vor ort ein tag vor ort finde ich gut ein tag die woche vor ort rest home office das
wäre so meine persönliche optimale kombination kombination
steile karrierechancen fahrer oder führungslaufbahn ich will keine führungslaufbahn machen leute
da hat mich mein alter chef schon also nicht nicht der jetzt gerade sondern der von noch
früher immer genervt mit ich möchte nie im leben führungs eine führungsposition haben
ich will nicht nach münchen ziehen aber die münchner jobs können gerne mit remote und
home office deutschland weit das ausschreiben und hätte ich auch keine schmerzen mit extra
gutscheine für check 24 tja ich meine ich finde es gar nicht mal schlecht ja aber es
ist mein viel zu weit weg oder frankfurt keine ahnung so infrastructure moment die die seite
ist mit dark reader definitiv kaputt infrastructure automation das ist tatsächlich was das könnte
vom titel gut passen zu dem was ich kann beziehungsweise was ich gerne machen will
ah ja chat übrigens für den fall der fälle für den für den kleinen für den kleinen
fall dass ihr irgendwie bei mir hier gerade im chat seid und ihr leute sucht oder in
der position seid wo ihr leute sucht und vielleicht auch öfters bei mir im stream guckt und
denke ja vielleicht ist das gar nicht schlecht bei uns oder vielleicht werder max gar nicht
schlecht bei uns guckt mal bei mir auf die kanalseite da gibt es meine email adresse
ihr könnt mir gerne was schreiben ich lese mir das alles durch wenn ihr das hier nicht
öffentlich öffentlich irgendwie im stream posten wollt also ich bin aktuell wirklich
am suchen und ich bin da auch offen für was wäre deine ideale position du meinst was
ich von der technik her mache gerne machen würde oder home office also meine meine ideale
position wäre ein tag die woche arbeiten drei tage die woche home office ja kein zukünftig
aber ja liegt nicht liegen und technisch muss ich sagen das was die bahn davon geschrieben
hat fand ich gar nicht schlecht ich interessiere mich für jede menge gebiete das seht ihr
auch im stream sei es irgendwelche automatisierungsdinger linux allgemein unterschiedlichste programmier
sprachen backend entwicklung frontend entwicklung teilweise machen wir hier sogar irgendwelche
microcontroller geschichte ich interessiere mich für alle möglichen themen aber ich muss
sagen so die devops schiene aus tools und automatisierung finde ich nice weil da kann
ich ein bisschen was programmieren und es haben andere sogar noch was davon was ich
gebast also was ich dann gebaut habe also das finde ich eigentlich nicht schlecht es
kommt natürlich immer auf das jeweilige unternehmen an nein nein nein wir machen keine umfrage
guck mal was soll da mal so eine umfrage ok wir machen eine umfrage wir machen eine umfrage
weil du es bist 5000 kanalpunkte sind 5000 kanalpunkte aber ich kann jetzt schon sagen
dass ich nicht zur bahn gehen werde ok ich mache eine umfrage mods ihr müsst ihr müsst
nicht ich mache soll max zur bahn gehen ja nein ich mache jetzt mal ich gebe jetzt mal
leute ich gebe euch jetzt alle alle kanalpunkte die kanalpunkte ab für 1000 kanalpunkte könnt
ihr extra abstimmen wir müssen mal ein bisschen kanalpunkte los werden hier war schön dass
du dass du deinen weg her gefunden hast ich will ich leute es ist egal was ihr macht es
ist egal was ihr abstimmt ich gehe nicht zur bahn ich habe ich habe euch vorhin gesagt
ich habe mir das nur just for fun angeguckt in hanao sogar und linux na dann zeigt mal
hier alter was ist das denn 92 prozent sagen ich soll zur bahn gehen leute ist überlegt
war realistisch betrachtet meint ihr die würden mich einstellen nachdem sie mein twitter profil
gesehen haben meint ihr wirklich die bahn würde mich einstellen nachdem sie sekunde
nachdem sie hier ich weiß ich jetzt sogar schon ein bisschen her dass ich bahn geflammt
habe moment ich muss mal kurz suchen na twitter nervt doch nicht rum mensch
meint ihr die wollen wirklich dass jemand dort arbeitet der schreibt auf bitter wie
ich diesen kack bahnlernen hasse und sind es schon fast 20 ich verachte euch wie nix
anderes oder ich habe auch schon irgendwas geschrieben ihr ihr dreckigen kackficker von
der bahn und so leute wenn die auf mein twitter profil gehen im lebendig
oder aber oder aber oder aber es ist so dass dann schon wenn ich mich da wenn ich da wenn
ich da zum ersten mal anröke und dass dann mein da das man damit der chef von dort sagt
er macht immer nur alter ich kann den laden auch nicht ab ne das funktioniert nicht ja
ja ganz bestimmt leute das funktioniert nicht ok leute ihr habt mir so viele links geschickt
ich weiß gar nicht wo ich wo ich anfangen soll wo ich anfangen soll zu gucken ehrlich
gesagt also wo sind wir wo sind wir denn eben stehen geblieben hier hier sind wir eben stehen
geblieben bei da also ach nee moment nee was soll ich mir angucken ok das hat das hat
da auch eben jemand geschickt also was was haben die denn hier du übernimmst die einrichtung
betreuen erweiterung unserer server ja gut das kann ich du bist am aufbau so wie der
optimierungsgelegenheit ja ok backer monitor auch ok du steuerst ja mache ich ja aktuell
auch einrichten und rollout der server wird ist es linux ist es linux ist es linux ist
es nicht windows es ist nicht windows ok das schon mal gut das schon mal sehr gut weil
windows würde ich nee automatisierungsfolge automatisch ja auch gut fundierte berufserfahrung
wie gesagt ich mache den kram seit 14 jahren ich glaube ich kenne mich da ganz gut mit
aus sollsteck habe ich keine ahnung n simple puppet kenne ich mich gut aus sichere umgang
nginx bash ok papf keine ahnung wie man damit sicher sein kann mysql gut mysql ist wie
gesagt ich bin ja der postgres mensch aber ich komme damit auch klar script ok das hat
die preis das hat die personalabteilung geschrieben ab und zu geht es kommt darauf an was so was
es da genau geht also prinzipiell schon klar kommt aber halt ich kann es schwer was zu
sagen aber wie gesagt wenn es wirklich irgendwas gibt ich habe auf meinem kanal wenn du auf
das logo klickst da gibt es im profil meine ich sage business email adresse also wenn
da wirklich interesse dran besteht und ich meine von meiner technischen kompetenz kann
man sich ja ab und zu auch im stream überzeugen ich freue mich über jeden der mir da was
was schickt ich werde auf alles antworten es kann natürlich sein dass das irgendwelche
gründen nicht passt ja zu weit weg oder irgendwie keine ahnung davon oder sonst was kann ja
kann ja alles sein aber wird mich freuen wenn du was hinschickst weil es sei denn du willst
den link hier posten im chat aber das wollen die meisten ja nicht ok also skript sprache
wie pp ergibt jetzt relativ wenig sinn weil wenn du im administrationsumfeld skriptest
du nix mit pp da machst du das mit bash zum größten teil oder eben mit n simple puppet
oder halt mit irgendwie peißen ruby sonst was aber nicht mit pp zu deinen stärken zählen
teamfähigkeit ja ich bin ja eigentlich da mal der meinung ich kann mit anderen menschen
nicht gut ja ihr kennt mich ich habe schon oft genug stories erzählt aber im letzten
kann ich jetzt erzählen weil ich könnte mir vorstellen er hört es gerade in meinem
letzten mitarbeitergespräch mit meinem chef mit meinem ehemaligen chef habe ich in meiner
bewertung drin stehen dass ich dass ich gut auf wie was stand da drin weiß es gar nicht
mehr genau das da dass ich besonders auch in schwierigen themen irgendwie gut teamübergreifend
oder sowas kommunizieren kann oder so hätte ich nie gedacht hat mich gefreut dass das
drin steht weil eigentlich kann ich ja nicht so gut mit anderen leuten aber so lang so
fachliche themen geht ist das ja kein problem ja aber zu gehen ist gute deutsch und englisch
kenntnis in worten schrift unten dein profil ab hast du ein zwischenzeugnis echt bekommen
bald bald chat gibt's gibt's bald gute deutsch und englisch naja also ich habe es geschafft
letzte woche mit drei leuten von der telekom oder vier leute vier leute von der telekom
waren sogar insgesamt rein auf englisch zweimal videokonferenz zu machen und mit denen zusammen
was zu installieren also ich bin jetzt nicht der krasse native speaker aber ich komme durch
irgendwie
work from anywhere bis zu vier mit mir geht es eher wie sieht es mit dem thema home office
aus dass ich von dass ich aus dem urlaub arbeiten kann ist nice aber mich würde eher interessieren
wie sieht es mit home office aus sonst könnte man das nämlich gleich vergessen mv tickets
wie sieht es denn mit home office aus ja für deine work life balance bieten wir dir flexibel
arbeitszeit eine faire home office regelung und mehr als 30 tage urlaub sind möglich 30
tage urlaub reichen mir home office regelung ist wichtig ehrlich gesagt ist das vom profil
ja gar nicht übel finde ich nicht schlecht also wer auch immer den job geschickt hat
nice passt wirklich gut ja ein tag die woche wohlgemerkt ein tag die woche ins büro nicht
ein tag die woche home office das fände ich in ordnung das ist das ist auch so das weiß
ich mir so als also die meine lieblings kombination ja ich mein guckt mal die können jetzt ja
schlecht das kann ich verstehen die können jetzt auch hier kaum in die bewerbung reinschreiben
wir garantieren ihnen das und das und im endeffekt passt irgendwas nicht aber spätestens wenn
du den vertrag unterschreibst oder sag mal so ich würde den vertrag nur unterschreiben
wenn es dann auch wirklich wirklich geregelt ist also ja ansonsten ansonsten läuft das
so wie da wo ich aktuell bin wo im vorfeld erzählt wird home office wir sind super modern
und agil und haben jetzt home office regelungen und sonst was und dann wenn sie leute wirklich
machen wollen sagt man doch er nicht ich habe es euch mal erzählt ein kollege von mir ist
sogar umgezogen dem haben sie erzählt überhaupt kein problem und auch mobil und unterwegs
und so alles kein ding oder ist wirklich umgezogen und jetzt ich glaube der war morgen sogar
im stream an der cover ich habe ihn ich habe ihn kurz gesehen und jetzt sitzt er da ja also
in der regel ist wahrscheinlich du hast recht wahrscheinlich ist es so gemeint mit die regelung
ist fair für check 24 aber gut ich meine wenn sie die leute überzeugen wollen von sich
dann hast du mit deinem teamleiter drüber ich habe das gesagt ja ich habe gesagt ich
werde ich werde jetzt ausprobieren mit 50 5 oh misto sind wir stehen geblieben ich werde
das jetzt also im ersten gespräch habe ich ihm gesagt wenn die wirklich jetzt anfangen
mit leute müssen quasi wieder komplett nach frankfurt kommen dann denke ich ernsthaft
drüber nach mir was neues zu suchen und letzte woche hatte ich schon mal ein gespräch wo es
ja die sonntag diese woche weiß das ja noch leute ist für euch sonntag der anfang oder
das ende der woche also für mich ist es das ende der woche diese woche habe ich noch mal
mit ihm gesprochen und er meinte jetzt besteht die firma irgendwie auf 50 50 und wir haben
uns halt das ende ok und da haben wir uns halt drauf geeinigt ja ich guck mir das jetzt
mal an er hat er hat als erstes gesagt werft man nicht die flinte gleich ins korn oder
so was habe ich schon gedacht ok wenn das dann ist glaube ich klar dass ich nicht damit
zufrieden bin und ich ich guck mir das jetzt schon an ich kann ich habe die drei drei
monate kündigungsfrist aber ich bin damit wirklich nicht happy und ich habe gar nicht
das problem ins büro zu gehen das ist es nicht das bahnfahren ist das was mich abfuckt
oder generell der arbeitsweg ist das was mich abfuckt besonders in kombination mit der bahn
das büro ist gar nicht so wild ist ja nicht dass ich was gegen die leute hätte oder so
zumindest nicht gegen die meisten auto ja das wäre das wäre vielleicht ein ticken weniger
nervig ein ticken weniger nervig wie mit der bahn aber auch nicht viel
wenn es wenn es ein wenn es dings gäbe schon komplett automatisiertes fahren dann würde
ich das machen aber ich will kein ai kein ai gesteuertes auto sehen was in der frankfurter
stadt rumdüst das kannst du klicken
also ich muss sagen wer das hier vorgeschlagen hat ist gar nicht schlecht das passt was unser
recruiting versprechen unsere spräche finden persönlich oder wieder via videokonferenz
statt sicheres onboarding vollzeit das bedeutet moment vollzeit dann ist es ja für mich gar
nix vollzeit ist nope no pass aber an sich von pastas von profiler wirklich nicht schlecht
so next nein vor ort ne kundenkontakt vor ort es gibt ja kaum was schlimmeres was ich
mir vorstellen kann ich will doch einfach nur das machen womit ich mich gut auskenne
und das ist technik kram ich will möglichst wenig mieten ich will möglichst wenig zwischenmenschliche
probleme ich will möglichst wenig endkundenkontakt ich will einfach das machen was ich gut kann
ich will so auf keller kind basis einfach ordentliche arbeit im technik it sektor abliefern
und das machen was ich gut kann das kann doch nicht so viel verlangt sein richtig genauso
sieht es aus wieso keine vollzeit irgendjemand hat es gerade gefragt hier wieso keine vollzeit
ja wann soll ich wann soll ich youtube twitch und andere sachen machen wenn ich vollzeit
arbeite außerdem verdiene ich über twitch und youtube mittlerweile recht gut nebenbei
sodass ich um über die runde zu kommen kein vollzeit mehr arbeiten muss ehrlich gesagt
wenn ich einfach nur über die runden kommen will könnte ich noch deutlich weniger arbeiten
als vier tage die woche aber ja wo ziehst du dann die grenze ja kremsel danke für den
sub technik influence nein wer ist nicht ich will twitch und youtube nicht vollzeit machen
verdienst du eigentlich wer mit youtube oder twitch kommt drauf an wenn ich irgendwelche
promotion geschichten mache dann eindeutig mit youtube wenn ich einfach nur streame und
bisschen sub sub gebühren von besaß bekomme dann über twitch also diesen monat habe ich
beispielsweise nicht viel auf youtube gemacht kein auch keine sponsorings auch nicht mit
hetsner nix und korrekt ja und ich habe am ende des monats keine ahnung was habe ich
gemacht mit youtube 400 euro oder so wahrscheinlich nicht ich denke nicht wobei ich habe relativ
viele views bekommen auf die videos ja das ist das ist mal 600 euro sein 600 euro 600
euro youtube und twitch könnt ihr euch ausrechnen kann ich euch sagen creator dashboard ich
habe die letzten tage bisschen weniger gestreamt dann ist es runtergegangen was habe ich denn
jetzt ich habe ganz genau 200 subs aktuell das heißt ich kriege ungefähr das gleiche
noch mal von twitch also ich bekomme ja 2,5 also 2,50 pro sub ist das überhaupt noch so
bekomme ich überhaupt noch 2,50 pro sub war da nicht irgendwas es sind zwei euro mittlerweile
noch das ist billiger geworden stimmt ok dann habe ich ok 400 also ich bekomme mit dem aktuellen
sub account bekomme ich 400 euro von twitch und wahrscheinlich irgendwas um 500 euro
von youtube aber in den in den monaten wo ich keinen sponsoring mache und quasi gar
nix auf youtube dann ist es mit twitch mehr aber wie gesagt es ist jetzt nicht dass ich
da super reich von werden würde in der aktuellen variante ich meine klar gibt bestimmt leute
die sagen ja klar von 1000 euro im monat kann man leben aber ihr dürft nicht vergessen
man muss da steuern drauf bezahlen und man muss davon ja auch leben das heißt man muss
davon was ausgeben das heißt es nicht dass 2000 dass 1000 euro auf dem konto ankommen
dann 1000 euro zum verpulvern da sind also damit kommt man nicht kommt man nicht über
die runden natürlich kann man jetzt sagen hey wenn ich das vollzeit machen würde ja
gut dann müsstest du halt jeden tag streamen oder jeden zweiten tag streamen und jeden
zweiten tag ein video machen oder so ja klar aber dann bin ich in zug zwang und muss content
produzieren obwohl ich keinen bock drauf habe also ich denke es ist für alle beteiligten
das beste sowohl für euch zum zugucken als auch für mich zum content createn wenn ich
das nicht vollzeit mache
wir ich sage schön für den sub jetzt sind übrigens mittlerweile schon 202 subs danke
für die subs leu echt das ist poch zeig mal was haben die das brauche ich
weiß es und auf deutsch machen nope preise only fans leute ich glaube das letzte von
dem ihr only fans sehen wollen ist von mir wobei ich mache mir einfach ein cute anime
grill avatar geht ja mittlerweile alles also was kostet denn der kram stimmt ok leute
habt recht sogar sogar der wendler hat only fans ok ich gebe zu es gibt sachen die kann
ich nicht nachvollziehen ja ich muss auf ipv6 only gehen
wisst ihr was ich was ich besser finden würde wenn die endlich server anbieten würden ganz
ohne public ip viele server brauchen keine public ip wozu wenn ich dort eine ernst zu
nehmende cloud infrastruktur betreiben würde dann würde ich das erste machen ist das interface
davon runterfahren oder eben die firewall an sie haben wirklich server ohne ip ja moment
cloud server wirklich cloud server oder oder nur die root kisten ich weiß dass man interne
netze machen kann aber trotzdem hat der server wenn du ihn kaufst eine externe ip es gibt
cloud nur mit private ip oh das ist gut das ist neu das letzte mal gab es das noch nicht
so weil das wünsche ich mir schon länger bei jetzt weil dann kann man nämlich zum
beispiel solche setups machen wie ein load balancer und drei application server oder
zwei eingänge und ein high iq five head kubernetes cluster wie kommt man dann drauf verschiedenste
an vpn ist eine möglichkeit aber ich würde wahrscheinlich ssh über irgendeinen jump
host machen oder sowas ich meine du brauchst ja irgendeine kiste auf die man von außen
drauf kommt damit du deine services anbieten kannst und sei es nur ein load balancer dann
gehe ich halt über den load balancer auf port port auf ssh port gehe ich dann hin und
hoppe weiter auf mein back end der chat postet mir weiterhin sachen hast du nie über als
wie gesagt habe ich werde ich nicht machen nico rock dankeschön für den sub was machst
du denn rententechnisch ich habe etf die etf sind dieses jahr aber wie soll ich sagen not
stonks nein nein ganz ehrlich alles was ich mitbekommen
habe von media marketing und influencer agenturen und sonst was das ist der komplette und ich
sag ich meine das ich meine ok ich muss das ich muss ich meine nicht alle die da arbeiten
ich meine ich kenne viele leute und mit ein paar würde ich sogar sagen bin ich sowas wie
befreundet über die jahre die dort arbeiten aber dieses ganze marketing agenturen kam
das sagen die leute selbst die dort arbeiten ist kompletter abschaum wie dort mit den leuten
umgegangen wird die verarschen von die verarschen ihre eigenen mitarbeiter komplett also influencer
marketing marketing gut media keine ahnung aber gerade influencer marketing ist der komplette
abschaum und wie gesagt ich meine nicht die leute die dort arbeiten jetzt persönlich sondern
diese ganze branche das ist komplette abschaum würde ich im leben nicht arbeiten und ich
bekomme das von paar leuten mit also ich kenne ja einige die dort arbeiten und ein paar verstehe
ich mich auch ganz gut und was man da teilweise für stories hört ist wirklich ich kann es
jetzt nicht erzählen ohne dass ich irgendwie aus versehen irgendwelche namen aus ausplappen
aber da ist verarscht werden an der tagesordnung
eine firma habe ich doch irgendwie muss ich doch beim finanzamt alles angeben was ich
mache sucht hetzner niemand wahrscheinlich schon guck mal mal job ist hetzner lass doch
mal gucken keck weight aber ich glaube ich kann schlecht mich sponsor lassen von hetzner
und dort arbeiten wofür kann man so einen server verwenden ja das einfachst du kannst
deine persönliche webseite drauf laufen lassen und noch vieles mehr kannst du alles drauf
laufen lassen was du laufen lassen willst und ohne public ip ist der vorteil wenn du
beispielsweise eine applikation hast über drei server verteilt mit dem laut balancer
davor dann brauchst du jetzt nicht zum beispiel der weltbekannte das weltbekannte open source
projekt keck wss service mit ganzen drei sternen ist zum beispiel darauf ausgelegt
diagonal zu skalieren über mehrere back end systeme ja ja es wird nicht nur horiton nicht
nur horiton zahl skaliert nicht nur vertikal skaliert es wird diagonal skaliert was kennst
du dass die welcome to search ne sagt mir gar nix so und das kannst du da super drauf
laufen lassen du machst den laut balancer an eingang drei applikationsserver dahinter
oder ein kubernetes cluster wenn man jetzt trendy sein will und dann brauchst du keine
public ips dafür außer für den eingang was gut ist spart geld und reduziert die angriff
fläche guck mal gleich hello world s warum hat er so what the f
okay das ist tibet oder das ist das ist tibet hello hello world in okay das ist das unvergleichs
der hello ja das ist tibet das ist das ist ein memeprojekt wahrscheinlich auch die einrückung
mit mit acht acht leerzeichen und die rakete ist wichtig ja okay zeig mal nun mal was was
was gibt es denn bei hetzner zur unterstützung unseres teams suchen wir ab sofort engagierte
kompetente mitarbeiter der fob systeme administration ab sofort faltenstein okay ja das wird schon
mal nix ja faltenstein ist ein bisschen weg damit kenne ich mich aus damit kenne ich mich
auch aus damit kenne ich mich auch aus würde ich sagen mit 14 oder eigentlich sind schon
15 jahre linux erfahrung damit kenne ich mich auch aus damit kenne ich mich auch aus
hoffe ich mal würde ich auch sagen würde ich auch sagen würde ich auch sagen sie ist
immer alle anforderungen erfüllt nur mit dem unterschied ich will nicht nach faltenstein
mit home office ist da nix tja dann und es ist vollzeit dann ich weg übrigens das ist
gut dass sie da schreiben kantine vor ort ist wirklich ein ziemlich großer pluspunkt
wenn man denn vor ort ist second level kunden kundensupport monka es kann man hier kann
man hier sortieren nach ups ne ne da nicht ne mache ich nicht das mache ich nicht was
würde ich machen wie gesagt ich will e home office und teilzeit ich gebe zu das ist vielleicht
nicht die alltäglichste kombination musst du deinen youtube kanal dann angeben wahrscheinlich
muss ich bei meinem aktuellen arbeit wobei ganz ehrlich ich weiß nicht ob ich es gemusst
hätte jetzt im nachhinein habe ich aber gemacht ja werde ich dann auch machen ich mein wo
ist das problem ist ja nix geheimes ich muss dir ja nicht ich muss dir noch nicht mal sagen
welcher kanal ich sage einfach nur medien erstellung content creator was genau geht
dir nix an ja das stimmt generell ist es ja auch so die die unternehmen können gar
nicht so viel sagen gegen wenn du wenn du eine weile da bist sagst du willst dann teilzeit
arbeiten ja wir können dich rausschmeißen aber ansonsten müssen sie sich mit dem thema
beschäftigen auf der suche auf der suche nach einer computer security abteilung ich
habe das wort von c-sharp review komplett gesehen ich war vom chat enttäuscht das stand
so viel 3 hat schrott aber das was du gemacht hast hatte hand und fußesse nice welches
welche welchen stream denn womit sie neuen features angeguckt haben oder letztens das
mit dem compiler mit dem out compiler weil das andere ist ja schon ein halbes jahr her
oder so ich gucke erstmal ja iot nicht aut war war nice ja was habe ich hier gerade aufgemacht
hier smart recruiter oh excellent ein computer computing fellowship am zern ok das ist glaube
ich über meine IQ klasse so das hat mir auch jemand im chat geschickt was macht eigentlich
die christliche die christliche stelle für den systemadministrator bei der bei der evangelischen
kirche oder was das war jesus ist mittelpunkt unseres arbeitens gibt es die noch ich weiß
nicht mal wie die hießen church tools genau offene stellen bei church tools begin entwickler
bei church tools endlich ja ich wollte schon immer mal ich wenn ich verwende ja auch nur
temple os ich wollte schon immer mal für jesus programmieren plus rng was man nicht
mal verwenden darf als emote jesus das ist uns wichtig der glaube an jesus verbindet
uns und spielt auch im alltag eine wichtige rolle ganz im ernst ich bin da äußerst ich
bin da äußerst pragmatisch wenn er mir 200.000 euro im jahr bezahlt glaube ich auch an jesus
das werden die aber wahrscheinlich nicht machen oh nein leute ne versteht mich nicht falsch
das sind nicht meine pauschalen gehaltsvorstellungen es muss aber ein bisschen was obendrauf gelegt
werden dass ich auch sage ich glaube an jesus segenstatt gehalt ja ok
im mobilen office mobil ist auch ok also ich kann auch so tun als sitze ich im zug wenn
ich daheim sitze soll mir recht sein technische ausstattung auf aktuelle bestand wenn das
schon ein pluspunkt ist ich meine es ist ehrlich gesagt es ist wirklich ein pluspunkt aber
ich finde es ist schon also es ist man glaubt es gar nicht wie viele unternehmen es lese
ich ja auch immer bei euch im chat überhaupt nicht in der lage sind ihre mitarbeiter ordentlich
auszustatten null also wahnsinn aber ich weiß nicht es wirkt immer so technisch ich würde
eigentlich das nicht reintun weil ich eigentlich davon ausgeben das sollte standard sein dass
man seine leute ordentlich ausstattet also wie gesagt für das notwendige gehalt glaube
ich auch an jesus wie du deine gaben bei church tool einbringen
könntest clean code ich glaube bei denen hättest du tatsächlich chancen wenn du dich
bewirbst und sagst ja ich kenne mich eher in dem dem und dem bereich aus aber der klautman
jesus verbindet uns ich könnte mir vorstellen dass sie da wirklich sehr viel wert drauf
legen und mal angenommen ich will das jetzt ja gar nicht so schlecht reden es soll ja
jeder glauben was er will und mal angenommen man ist wirklich so richtig tiefgläubig und
und je gelobet sei der her und was praise jesus und keine ahnung dann ist das glaube
ich wirklich eine gute gelegenheit für jemand weil im ernst so viel gibt es das nicht also
wenn jemand wirklich gläubig ist und und da den ganzen tag am beten ist und auch immer
vom essen beten so jemand dem das quasi schon in fleisch und blut übergegangen ist und
dem das irgendwie was gibt ist das glaube ich wirklich eine gute gelegenheit weil so
viele gibt es nicht in der richtung ich meine für mich ist das nix ich bin so ziemlich
der ungläubigste vom ungläubigen ja das geht sogar so weit jetzt keinen scherz leute
ich habe schon mails bekommen auf noch sogar schon zu call of duty zeiten und ich erzähle
euch mist es waren keine mails es waren damals wahrscheinlich sogar noch youtube pn da gab
es leute die wollten mich zum islam bekehren die haben meine videos gerne geguckt und die
wollten nicht dass ich in die hölle komme und und warum war nicht mein weg zu allah
finde weil ich halt in meinen videos immer gesagt hab aller ihr könnt mir mit mit glauben
und und sowas kann ich überhaupt nichts anfangen und die wollten mich wirklich weil sie meine
videos und meinen content mochten überzeugen weil sie nicht wollten dass ich in die hölle
komme ist ja schon nett gemeint irgendwie aber mich kannst du weder mit jesus noch mit
allah überzeugen der einzige der einzige der mich mit seinen ansichten halbwegs überzeugen
kann ist der dalai lama und ich würde garantiert auch nicht zum hinduismus konvertieren und
dann irgendwie buddha ist irgendwie erleuchtet machen ich finde die die die betrachtungsweisen
die der dalai lama manchmal auf twitter postet nicht schlecht
diese piraten seite muss man in meinem video gucken
das ist cool die kenn ich bei denen habe ich schon mal irgendwann irgendwas gehostet kommt
nicht die so gutes weltunterstützung haben ich glaube das habe ich mal ausprobiert bei
denen germany ihr land ok die wollen dass man krasse englisch speaker ist wahrscheinlich
wenn zum digitalisierung und technik jetzt sind wir schon in der hölle
wahrscheinlich hat wenn es die hölle gibt haben sie wahrscheinlich dort glasfaser schon
übrigens wissen das gar nicht so einfach ist diesen diesen durchsichtigen klasseffekt
hier hinzubekommen mit css habe ich auch schon probiert das geht aber dass es schön aussieht
ist gar nicht so einfach gerade mit einer sticky navigation bar suchst du eigentlich
auch mehr gehalt oder erst mal nur weg also ich suche nicht unbedingt erst mal nur weg
also ich finde den land wo ich bin ja gar nicht so schlecht ich habe aber keinen bock
auf 50 prozent der tage der tage in der woche wieder bahn fahren sollten die sich das jetzt
in nächster zeit noch anders überlegen weil es gibt hat ja mein neuer chef gesagt es
gibt ja gespräche und so dann kann ich mir auch durchaus vorstellen dass ich da bleibe
er aber da wird halt so viel erzählt wenn der tag lang ist das heißt ich glaube da
mittlerweile nicht dran dass ich da was tun wird also ich will nicht unbedingt jetzt nur
weg es gibt einen grund der mir auf den sack geht weshalb ich weg will und warum ich mir
jetzt auch erst mal angucke was es so gibt ich werde nicht halt über kopf sagen morgen
bin ich weg ich werde erst mal gucken dann werde ich nächste woche mal mit denen in frankfurt
reden also mit denen was ich euch heute morgen erzählt habe dann mal gucken wie das mit
den anderen aussieht dann werde ich mir was raus und ich werde einfach mal gucken und
dann bin ich weg wenn sich bis dahin nichts geändert hat das wird sicherlich 1 2 monate
dauern bis ich mir das alles schon angeguckt habe und wenn ich was gutes finde dann bin
ich weg es sei denn es hat sich bis ich was gutes gefunden habe was ergeben dass es eben
mit home office doch besser möglich ist aber glaube ich nicht wie gesagt ich habe da ich
habe da die die hoffnung da aufgegeben dass da irgendwas rauskommt chat ich kann jetzt
nicht so sehr im detail was zu erzählen aber das muss ich nicht das muss ich nicht weil
weder mein jetziger aktueller chef noch der chef davor waren gegen home office wenn es
nach denen gegangen wäre hätten wir alle viel mehr home office gemacht die höheren
etagen sind das die das unbedingt wollen weil die solche dinge erzählen wie wir sind
ein präsenzbetrieb und hier arbeiten menschen mit menschen ich meine wir verkaufen fucking
versicherungen warum muss ich mit menschen arbeiten wenn ich im back end für linux server
verantwortlich bin das hat mit menschen doch nichts zu tun dieses geschwätze da immer
man doch es ist eine bank aber auch banken verkaufen versicherungen da werden so da werden
so random dinge erzählt das highlight das highlight war wo mal erzählt wurde ja dass
es nicht so viel home office gibt ist ja um die leute vor sich selbst zu beschützen dass
sie nicht vereinsamen und sowas da musste ich nur noch kecken als ich das gehört habe
weil ganz im ernst ganz im ernst wenn der arbeitgeber uns beschützen möchte vor
gefahren dann müsste er uns auf jeden fall auch davor schützen mit dem auto zur arbeit
zu fahren weil das ist deutlich gefährlicher als daheim sitzen drei monate ja
aber natürlich wenn ich denn schon den job wechsle dann muss es auch in gewisser weise
mit dem gehalt passen aktuell habe ich ja den vorteil dass wir noch also dass ich neben
dem normalen gehalt und und bonus sachen die drinne stehe auch jedes mal erhöhen
bekomme wenn im tarifvertrag irgendeine erhöhen geplant wird und wenn der nächste arbeitgeber
kein tarifvertrag hat das muss zumindest perspektivisch passen ja also ich schiele
schon darauf dass ich wenn ich den job wechsle mehr geld bekomme und vor allem und das ist
mir wichtig dass man von anfang an sich eine ja so zukunftsperspektive irgendwie überlegt
wie sich das wie sich das entwickeln kann die nächsten jahre weil ansonsten ist das
wieder so aus wie sagt man so aus dem kopf aus dem sinn so nach dem motto ja da ändert
sich nie wieder was dran außer du gehst uns drei monaten auf den keks glaub mir in dem
fall weiß ich dass mein mein chef selbst für home office ist das können wir klappen
ich habe ja noch ich muss ja noch gar nicht mal 100 prozent ich will ja gar kein 100 prozent
home office wie gesagt ein tag die woche ich arbeite nur vier tage ein tag die woche
ist vollkommen ok geht zu google da muss ich den binary tree inverten an der tafel das
kann ich nicht
korrekt leute ich spare richtig geld durch home office richtig massiv geld durch home
office allein habe ich nicht mehr so viel futtern ich habe abgenommen ich habe fast
15 kilo abgenommen leute mittlerweile stelle euch das mal vor ich habe lange kein wagen
update mehr gepostet wäre es die scharp dotnet entwicklung was für dich das problem ist
was sie scharp dotnet entwicklung angeht ich habe keinerlei erfahrung als professioneller
software entwickler in größeren teams ich würde schon sagen ich habe ziemlich viel
ahnung von dotnet und sie scharp im allgemeinen also es ist nicht so dass ich mir das technisch
nicht zutraue aber ich habe als vollzeit profi entwickler keine erfahrung und ich weiß
nicht überhaupt gar nicht ob vollzeit entwickler überhaupt was für mich ist ich meine wir
machen hauptsächlich dotnet und sie scharp wenn wir programmier streams machen weil es
mein mit abstand lieblings framework runtime und programmiersprache ist aber ich weiß
nicht ob ich professioneller entwickler werden will ich muss sagen der linux defops bereich
gefällt mir ehrlich gesagt besser für die tägliche arbeit was ich gerne habe ist und
wo ich auch wirklich happy bin dass das mal mein letzter chef so gemanagt hat die letzten
jahre über wenn ich in dem bereich die ein oder anderen tools programmieren kann also
dass ich sachen entwickeln kann wo ich dann unterm strich auch sehe ja die bringen was
von automatisierung bis irgendwelche helfer tools bis automatische tests von von sonst
was oder automatische informationsauslesen aus unterschiedlichen system aggregieren
irgendwo anders hinschreiben einfach dass ich die letzten jahren bisschen mehr programmieren
konnte und dass es halt eben auch was gebracht hat was ich gemacht habe damit das finde
ich gut ja also deswegen der linux defops bereich das was wir uns am anfang lustigerweise
bei der bahn angeguckt haben ist genau das was ich machen will oder weitermachen will
das mache ich ja schon lange moin michael 50 jahren lange nicht mehr gesehen ja das
ist das was ich vorhin meinte es manager gucken nicht immer nur auf die zahlen weil wenn es
nach den zahlen geht ist bei uns die it wunderbar aufgestellt was homeoffice angeht und gerade
bei mir persönlich sieht man das auch denke ich jetzt mal also man sieht zumindest dass
es nicht schlechter geworden ist aber ich denke man sieht auch dass die ergebnisse gut
sind und wenn ich sogar besser als vor homeoffice auch von auch von von der arbeit die geschafft
wird aber das interessiert bei dem wo ich aktuell bin kein die haben irgendein bauchgefühl
dass homeoffice schlecht ist im oberen management und bringen dann immer irgendwelche pauschalen
sprüche sowie wir sind menschen die mit menschen arbeiten und menschen arbeiten am besten mit
menschen und präsenz und bla und sonst ergibt keinen sinn aus meiner sicht warum ich als
it keller kind präsenz sein muss für sachen die ich nicht in präsenz machen muss aber
ok ja das ist bei uns nicht unbedingt rein faktenbasiert das ist eher manager bauchgefühl
das ist auch was was mich persönlich ziemlich abfuckt dass man eben gesehen hat die letzten
zweieinhalb jahre dass das ziemlich gut funktioniert und auch gerade bei uns im bereich ziemlich
gut funktioniert deshalb keinen interessiert pfeife macht es ich habe abgenommen im homeoffice
und wisst ihr warum ich abgenommen habe im homeoffice weil ich weniger fettiges essen
esse und pass mal auf super krasser trick zum abnehmen da kommt ihr nie drauf mehr bewegen
ich gehe jeden tag eineinhalb bis zwei stunden ich sage laufen und ich meine damit nicht joggen
ich meine laufen wandern zwei stunden ist in mittlerweile eher zwei stunden am tag zwei
stunden wandern am tag bisschen bisschen im spessart bei uns ein bisschen so ich mag
das wenn es ein bisschen hügelig ist also so rein ich meine ich meine ich laufe auch
mal irgendwie zur eisdiele am main lang das sind irgendwie neun kilometer oder so aber
das mag ich nicht ich mag das wenn es ein bisschen hügelig ist ja so ein bisschen durch
am waldrand bisschen hügelig und so bei uns spessart ausläufer ist wunderbar und seitdem
ich immer die eineinhalb zwei stunden am tag laufen gehe wandern gehe und ich ein bisschen
weniger und vor allem weniger fettig esse das klappt easy ich mein guckt mal auf twitter
leute ich habe euch immer mal wagen updates gepostet twitter alter jetzt ist gut ich habe
euch immer mal wagen updates gepostet twitter warum was soll ich machen nitter nitter ok
letztes wagen update 96,3 das ist aber auch schon wieder ein halben monat her ok 15 kilo
war übertrieben ich habe jetzt ich habe jetzt 95 irgendwas ich sage mal 95 3 ja 95 3 angefangen
habe ich bei 108,5 also es sind es sind nicht es sind 13 kilo sind 13 kilo wie groß bist
ich bin 174 ich bin immer noch pepo fett aber nicht mehr so pepo fett wie noch vor
ein paar monaten das ist die beste china chinesen wage die wird über bluetooth ausgelesen mit
dem esp 32 und dann in meine heim automatisierung geschrieben dass ich ein graf habe wie sich
mein gewicht entwickelt wie ist der body mass index in dem fall wahrscheinlich ziemlich
schlecht aber bmi rechner passt mal auf mein body mass index ist bestimmt massive zu fett
ich bin 37 74 komm ich runde ich bin mal nett ich runde mal ein bisschen ab ich runde ab
ok 95,3 sie wiegen etwas ok ist nur etwas nur etwas zu viel leute nur etwas zu viel
moment mit 21 habe ich übergewicht mit 37 ist aber etwas zu viel was hat das alter damit
zu tun und wenn ich 100 bin ist das eingabefeld welches eingabefeld es gibt kein eingabefeld
flashbang wo ist das eingabefeld jebaited einfach nur jebaited ach das ist ne ach das
100 aber mit 100 ist das ok ok verstehe also ich bin ich bin etwas sie wiegen etwas zu
viel normales gewicht ist 63 bis 81 leichtes übergewicht habe ich leute guckt mal ich
bin ich bin von von richtig viel zu fett jetzt runter auf leicht zu fett ist doch schonmal
nicht schlecht oder
gewicht 95 körpergröße 47 oh hier hier soll ich ernsthaft versuchen abzunehmen ja was
denn jetzt ja also zumindest ich habe euch ja meine waage schon öfters mal gezeigt das
letzte update war 6 90,3 ja so sieht das ungefähr aus wo ich immer wandern gehe so ich sage
hügelig hügelig ist pock und ihr müsst sagen es sieht es sieht doch es sieht auch nett aus
oder sieht doch nett aus so nitter ist ein twitter frontend oh chico ist teilweise so
niedlich oder guckt euch mal an hier chico chico chico so so waage waage waage wollte
ich euch zeigen hier 96,3 dann gehts weiter nächste waage 97,6 acht nach 98,5 oh gefährlich
weiß ich ob ich davor schon was gepostet habe 99,4 bei amazon kriegste die waage
noch joshi ich glaube das war es mit waage die ich gepostet habe da ist noch einer zu
fett guck mal ich glaube das war es mit waage die ich gepostet habe nutzt du die smart funktion
der waage nähe ich übertrags über bluetooth
denkst du es macht sinn nach meiner ausbildung wenn ich den neuen arbeitsvertrag kriege direkt
die vier tage warum nicht ich kanns nur empfehlen ich kanns nur empfehlen vier tage die woche
immer zu arbeiten beste beste was es gibt nö mach ich nicht mach ich nicht und zwar
wie gesagt ich sage wenn ich laufen sage meine ich nicht joggen ich meine wirklich laufen
wandern bisschen berg hoch berg runter und da gucke ich mir tatsächlich an wie es drum
herum aussieht so blöds klingt ich finde es ganz gut dass man nichts auf dem kopf hat
also nichts auf den ohren hat und und einfach ein bisschen rumgucken kann nein die waage
lese ich im esp32 aus bluetooth
kann ich machen
das ist tatsächlich so ja das ist das ist das ist so es ist auch das wenn leute denken
dass programmierer acht stunden am tag programmieren also software entwickler acht stunden am tag
programmieren das ist ja auch sprachsinnig was denkst du über diese teambank stellenanzeige
welche war das denn jetzt das da ich weiß nicht welche welche davon ach das da ja genau
das sollte das sollte ich mir angucken korrekt hat mir jemand gepostet also zeigt mal her
infrastructure und automation engineer wieder nur männlich weiß deutsch oder besser gesagt
deutsch männlich weiß sogar nur das aber im jahr 2022 echt fragwürdig also wir möchten
uns gerne bei dir vorstellen team bank ag ist mit der produktfamilie easy das sagt mir
was easy easy credit ich glaube mit denen mit denen machen wir irgendwas easy credit kommt
mir bekannt vor ich glaube mit denen haben wir irgendwas zu tun auf der arbeit frei nach
dem motto gestalten statt verwalten bla bla bla ok also du gestaltest erarbeitung von
sie was was ist es noch mal für infrastructure und automation engineer ok also systemarchitektur
für den aufbau neuer applikation da steht aber nicht ok meine mit infra die meinen eigentlich
architekt das ist was anderes was sie hier schreiben na gut überlesen wir das mal definition
und bereitstellen von infrastruktur ressourcen für den aufbau mein die damit server einbauen
ne oder das ist sehr schwammig geschrieben keine ahnung verwaltung aller infrastruktur
ressourcen des unternehmens bei allen provide an on-premis das das entwickelt sich in halber
it abteilung so langsam aber sicher weiterentwicklung automatisierung der prozess zur bereitstellung
verwaltung der infrastruktur ressourcen und das ist das ist sowieso schwammig ok du bringst
du bringst mit ein erfolgreich abgeschlossen studium ok bla bla bla das schrei mir alles
gleiche mehrjährige berufserfahrung im bereich infrastruktur management und systemarchitektur
weiß ich ob man das so nennen kann ein grundsätzliches verständnis von junix linux betriebssystem
damit kenne ich mich ehrlich gesagt hauptsächlich aus infrastruktur management und systemarchitektur
kann man nicht wirklich sagen dass ich da jetzt meinen schwerpunkt drin hatte eitel
oje praktische erfahrung mit einer oder mehreren der folgende technologien cloud technologien
dienste open stack aws azure ja hab ich formen seriously das kenne ich das haben wir auch
eine weile verwendet das ist das sind die mit diesem mit diesem gelben helm als logo
das ist ruby on rails anwendung ja die haben wir auch das haben wir auch eine weile verwendet
das kenne ich terraform kenne ich auch softwareentwicklung python go bash kenne ich mich auch aus scrum
kanban leute ich ich bin der agilste software der der agilste devops engineer der welt ich
habe sogar eine geeigene agilitäts linkedin seite da kann mir keiner was vormachen container
okress ich meine ich skaliere sogar diagonal also wenn ich gar wir haben es oft genug im
stream gehabt meine lösungen skalieren nicht horizontal nicht vertikal die skalieren diagonal
in beide richtungen gleichzeitig container orchestrierungswerkzeuge kooper ne das confidence
puppet ansible habe ich plan von jenkins gitlab kenne ich mir auch gut mit aus nagios
etschinger prometos ok prometos kenne ich mich recht gut mit aus nagios seriously wenn
die wirklich jemand suchen der sich mit nagios gut auskennt dann bin ich ihr mann finde heute
mal eine ahnung von nagios hat ich habe noch während meiner ausbildung zwei jahre als
als einziger typ nagios administriert bei uns und habe komplett neue damals eine komplett
neue nagios instanz mit nape agents selbst kompiliert noch für susie enterprise linux
und was wir alles für müll gemacht haben beim provider ich kann mich noch dunkel dran
immer also wenn die wirklich ein nagios kenner suchen dann bin ich wahrscheinlich einer der
wenigen die sie da finden heutzutage von ich würde es aber nicht unbedingt bevorzugen
mehr nagios zu machen ich bin da nicht so scharf drauf also nagios hat immer noch irgendwie
platz in meinem herz ja ich mag nagios aber ich möchte nagios nicht unbedingt hauptberuflich
machen logging tools elastics deck craylock der elks deck ist am start eine attraktive
vergütung ach verspricht jeder wir setzen eine umfassende betriebliche altersvorsorge
ach ja da fällt mir gerade was ein ich habe mich ja damals auch für die betriebliche
altersvorsorge entschieden bei meinem jetzigen arbeitgeber einfach weil sich das rein aus
einzahlungsgründen lohnt wenn der arbeitgeber irgendwie 300 euro oder so im monat ein bezahlt
für mich ich bezahle ein der arbeitgeber bezahlt ein so allein schon aus dem grund
habe ich das damals gemacht wie ist das denn jetzt eigentlich wenn ich den arbeit da muss
ich mich echt mal ein bisschen schlau machen wenn ich den arbeitgeber wechsle ich meine
dass es nicht verfällt ist mir klar aber was passiert dann die kannst du mitnehmen ja da
muss der neue arbeitgeber aber sagen sie übernehmen das
wie viele arbeitgeber hattest du soll ich ehrlich sein 2 ok das stimmt nicht ihr wisst
dass ich früher mal was mit bvl gemacht habe ganz früher ganz ganz früher ich erzähle
es ungern aber ja also wenn man das mit zählt dann drei aber das zähle ich nicht mit weil
das ist aus einem anderen leben mit dem ich nichts mal zu tun haben will also ich habe
meine ausbildung bei einem provider gemacht habe danach beim provider ein paar jahre gearbeitet
und jetzt arbeite ich bei einer bank in frankfurt und da bin ich jetzt auch schon seit 10 jahren
ziemlich zehn jahre doch ich habe sie dieses jahr habe ich zehnjähriges jubiläum leute
gucken wir mal ob ich es schaffe was neues zu finden bevor ich mal ein zehnjähriges
habe wobei man zehnjähriges hatte ich am anfang des jahres aber es gibt demnächst
so eine zehn jahres jubiläumsfeier wo alle eingeladen werden die zehn jahre jubiläum
haben und ich habe übrigens schon abgesagt kein witz ich habe kein bock auf offline veranstaltung
ich habe meine ich habe meine zehnjahre jubiläumsfeier abgesagt mal gucken ob ich es schaffe was
neues zu finden bevor ich meine zehnjahre jubiläumsfeier habe keller kinder i l ja so
ist es anscheinend ja moin da ist ja also it technisch zwei arbeitgeber ausbildung
beim provider paar jahre gearbeitet beim provider und jetzt seit zehn jahren bei einer bank
in frankfurt und das schon seit ich überlege gerade ich kann euch das relativ genau sagen
wisst ihr wisst ihr woran ich das woran ich das weiß das muss ich jetzt mal ein bisschen
ausholen ich wollte gerade sagen ich arbeite ja auch schon im deffops bereich seit es den
namen deffops noch gar nicht gibt also sprich was so sachen angeht wie infrastruktur als
code ordentliches repo management mit git wir haben git benutzt da hat es also ich habe
damals in git lab mit git bei uns etabliert da war git noch überhaupt nicht hip also
wir machen den kram schon länger als es deffops heißt ich mache den kram schon länger als
es deffops heißt natürlich am anfang auch viel verkackt weil es noch nichts gab worauf
man zurückgreifen konnte aber ich habe in dem bereich schon ahnung was ich mache und
wo wollte ich jetzt drauf raus habe ich vergessen worauf ich eigentlich drauf raus wollte ich
wollte nicht darauf raus dass ich der geilste checker auf der welt bin das war nicht mein
ziel jetzt ich weiß nicht mehr
keine ahnung was ich sagen wollte home office sehr gut sehr gut excellent wird gleich gespeichert
ja jetzt ich weiß nicht worauf ich raus ich wollte auf irgendwas aus dem chat antworten
aber jetzt habe ich zu lange ausgeholt und jetzt ist vorbei das weiß ich nicht mehr
ah ja genau das hier da drauf wie gesagt beim provider und ja jetzt jetzt jetzt weiß ich
wieder jetzt jetzt weiß ich wieder worauf ich raus wollte ich kann euch schon relativ
lange sagen seit wann ich diese deffops geschichte noch bevor es überhaupt deffops hieß obwohl
es bevor es den deffops bereich überhaupt gab wie lange ich das mache weil ich habe
den kram damals eingeführt bei uns angefangen von einem git repo wo wir dann unseren damals
noch zum größten teil puppet code committed haben mit pull requests mit review verfahren
mit einem jenkins damals der automatische sachen getestet also wie gesagt ich habe deffops
nicht über 30 ich habe das mit erfunden bei uns in der firma und ich kann euch das
an einer an einer sache sagen wie lange ich das schon mache wie lange das her ist weil
es gibt jeden monat bei uns außer december gibt es ein neues ich nenne es mal release
also sprich wir machen zwar trotzdem zwischendurch package updates und config anpassungen sowas
aber es gibt einmal im monat einen kontrollierten config management rollout bei uns über dieses
system was ich da etabliert habe die letzten jahre und die zähle ich einfach durch wir
haben angefangen bei eins und jetzt ende des jahres sind wir bei version 100 und ich mache
es seit version eins das heißt wir machen es 100 monate minus december wer ist wer ist
gut quickmaps also ich meine 100 durch 12 ist relativ einfach dann sind acht jahre aber
lassen wir mal die lassen wir mal december raus dann mache ich das halt ungefähr neun
jahren macht euch 11 ja stimmt das mache ich seit neun jahren ich habe das also wenn
einer erfahrung im devops bereich hat dann ich ich habe den kram mit eingeführt bei
uns und betreue das seit neun jahren also ich denke man kann sagen ich kenne mich da ganz
gut aus was hältst du für eine art costellerie monat welche davon war das jetzt gucke ich
mir gleich an gucke ich gucke ich mir gleich an welche war das denn das da das da gucke
ich mir gleich an jetzt machen wir erst mal schnell das das das haben wir hier durch
die versell stellen ja und ich angeguckt also das haben wir schon durch also habe ich mehr
oder weniger von allem ahnung was da steht nicht in der tiefe von wie gesagt von java
habe ich keinen plan von open stack auch nicht aber von den die ganzen punkte kann ich eigentlich
abhaken ein lebensarbeitszeit konto was für ein ding das klingt ja fast schon bedrohlich
ja das finde ich schon mal gut home office auf weltweite learning ok wollt ihr leute
wie mich abschrecken dann schreibt rein ihr schickt die leute auf weltweite learning journeys
ich gehe nicht auf weltweite learning journeys ich mache meinen job bei euch und ich sorge
dafür dass es ein gutes ergebnis abgeliefert wird aber ich gehe nicht auf weltweite learning
journeys wann soll ich streamen wann soll ich youtube machen ich gehe nicht auf weltweite
learning journeys interessant finde ich aber nicht schlecht passt vom profil ja auch relativ
gut das heißt du wirst offen von c sharp auf java bei der arbeit zu wechseln ich bin kein
hauptberuflicher entwickler ich bin ich habe auch nicht wirklich vor hauptberuflicher entwickler
zu werden und nein java entwickler möchte ich eher nicht werden also was haben wir hier
zu bieten system administrator in linux ach nee system administrator in in linux quasi
ist nicht es ist kein system administrator in linux ja manchmal ist es schon ein bisschen
schlecht zu lesen all genders welcome alles klar das heißt ich kann ich kann mich da
auch als als keks direkt bewerben was ist denn eigentlich mein richtiges pronoun als keks
it oder oder they they ist ist beliebt ich bin mehrere it them them them das eine gute
idee nats nats finde ich auch gut iot or das ist geil leute das muss man echt machen iot
iot finde ich top möchte gerne immer mit mit iot gegendered werden ok also wie was
was gibt es hier wenn es gibt eine gls bank ich dachte die transportieren nur nur pakete
unser ziel in den nächsten jahren zu den erfolgreichsten manag cloud provider für
mittlere und große da habt ihr was zu tun ok aufgaben die dich und und uns begeistern
it brains wanted leute 5 hat sie möchten 5 header haben hi iq chat 100 150 eq einstieg
also du lieferst technischen input für die konzeption konfiguration sowie den betrieb
von cloud infrastrukturen für digitalisierungsprojekte ok dein herz schlägt für ci cd ansible kubernetes
und terraform tatsächlich gut ich mein die ersten beiden themen sind poc die letzten
beiden terraform finde ich sehr nice kubernetes ist halt so ein ding ich kann darauf was deployen
ja ich würde aber nicht unbedingt sagen dass kubernetes administrieren eine tätigkeit
ist die mir wahnsinnig spaß macht vielleicht bin ich nicht cloud native genug dafür ja
du hast freude an der umsetzung moderne in verschwinden der fobs betriebskonzept ja
das habe ich teamwork makes the stream oh gott das ist eines der ausgelutschteste sprüche
aller zeiten nein nein ich doch ausform kubernetes ist schon das beste in der richtung vor allem
das verbreitet so und das mit den besten mit den besten ressourcen zu kubernetes hat
sich nicht ohne kund durchgesetzt aber ich finde dass das also ich möchte kein nicht
unbedingt hauptberuflich unbedingt kubernetes administrieren also aus dem is warm dead das
ist einfach nicht meins es ist ein unterschied zwischen ich kann es benutzen und ich habe
richtig spaß dran das ist einfach der unterschied hier habe ich richtig bock drauf hier habe
ich richtig bock drauf hier nicht auch richtig bock drauf aber kubernetes cluster verwalten
sowas ich weiß nicht spaß hat er nur an z plus plus so ist es leute so ist es vor allem
spaß haben wir z plus plus zu meckern gemeinsam mit deinem team entwickelt es zu projekte
übrigens schön leute dass so viele da sind heute wir haben ungefähr 100 zuschauer mehr
als sonst das ist massive ok weiter gemeinsam mit deinem team du findest ok per ticket system
oder am telefon tauschen ja ok die bereitschaft zur ruft moment ach so ja das ist ok das ist
ok bis zu achtmal im jahr übernimmst du jemals ja das das das lässt sich wenn das wenn
das entsprechend bezahlt wird immerhin dass wenn es passend bezahlt wird ist das ok es
ist die frage wie diese ruftbereitschaft sind also das haben wir ja bei uns auch ab und zu
mal nur bei uns geht glücklicherweise relativ selten was kaputt in den zeiten wo du bereitschaft
hast also wenn das so bereitschaften sind wo immer was am abkacken ist dann habe ich
da keinen bock drauf ok also was wollen remote work gleich schon mal speichern das ist ein
richtig guter benefit leute windows oder linux deine entscheidung das sieht man leider viel
zu selten viele wollen dich zwingen irgend so komische verkackte firmen windows installation
zu benutzen die überhaupt nicht richtig funktioniert dann noch lieber ordentliche linux kiste arch
by the way auf desktop natürlich nur arch only wer was anderes wer was anderes macht
hyper cringe cringe 3d ok remote work top unbefristeter arbeitsvertrag ja gut der ist
unbefristet bis die dass die unbefristet heißt er im prinzip auch nur du musst dich an die
kündigungsfristen halten unbefristet dass er nicht dass der das heißt nur dass er nicht
automatisch ausläuft die drei auf der arbeit ja klar habe ich das linux user das ist das
ist ein vga port wo steckt er den rein und ein serieller port ist das oder serial port
ein weyland kannst du knicken gerade in der vm sagt weyland aber macht dass das ist ein
discursiv display oder was macht er da dran ja genial top top plot plot vermieden so muss
das sein also weyland kannst du gerade in der vm komplett vergessen also unbefristete
und flexibler mentorin ist das irgendjemand der jede woche mit mir meine tickets durchgehen
will und gucken ob ich alles schön geupdatet habe das nervt mich eher individuelle einarbeitung
vereinbarkeit beruf und familie betriebs bla bla gym ein gym gibt es leute ein gym ein
ruheraum team event und legendäre jakuta krieg ich eh nicht hin leute ich bin seit zehn
jahren jetzt bei der bank in frankfurt von zehn einladungen zur weihnachtsfeier was
meint ihr wie oft ich auf der weihnachtsfeier war ihr kennt mich okay die ausfall ist null
oder einmal anscheinend die korrekte antwort ist noch nie ich war noch nie auf der weihnachtsfeier
nein nein nein das war nicht das war nicht bei der bank das war noch als ich azubi war
das war noch als ich azubi war beim provider mit der frau zum zugbring ja das ist schon
länger her dein profil ok also was wollen sie haben zeig mal her du weißt was gute
it lösungen im linux und automatisierung umfeld ausmachen und bist dahingehend profil
in der umsetzung ich mein selbstlob stinkt ja aber ich würde schon sagen dass ich mich
mit 14 jahren linux erfahrung durch als als linux profi bezeichnen darf und ich denke
was man bei mir im stream auch schon die ein oder andere male gesehen hat untermauert das
dass ich mich da doch brauchbar mit auskenne ja so im umgang mit entzettel und terraform
kannst du service und ja das kann ich entzettel haben wir sogar im stream auch schon gemacht
windows oracle kritisch kritisch ich administriere keine windows server postgres ja postgres
ist die beste datenbank aber mssql oracle und windows server nopas ja mit mit kvm kenne
ich mich ganz gut aus vmw ist halt so ein ding ja ich kenne mich mit vmw im punto desktop
virtualisierung aus und ja ich habe auch mal ein esx installiert und darauf vms laufen
lassen aber ich weiß dass das also ich kenne das von von unseren virtualisierungsleuten
auf der arbeit vmw das vmw ökosystem ist eine komplett eigene welt für sich das kann
man nicht so nebenbei mal machen oder vielleicht hast du ein bisschen ahnung davon weil du
es früher mal gemacht hast du brennt für automatisierung ok das hat die personalabteilung
da reingeschrieben die die fachabteilung hat gesagt wir suchen jemanden mit automatisierung
und die die personalabteilung hat daraus gemacht du brennt für automatisierung ich finde diese
bezeichnung immer so geil ich brenne für das ist so das ist so dass ich brenne das
klingt irgendwie ja das ich meine mir ist klar was sie damit meinen ja die essen genau
mir ist klar die meinen das ist was was dich wirklich interessiert wo du mit spaß bei
der sache bist ja wo du engagiert bist ich finde diese formulierung mit du brennst immer
irgendwie finde ich irgendwie blöd du warst du weißt was eine gute cloud lösung aus
machen hast erfahrung mit kubernetes oder microsoft asia gesammelt alle bereits ja habe
ich aber wie gesagt kubernetes administrieren wäre ich nicht so scharf drauf mit microsoft
asia habe ich tatsächlich schon einige erfahrungen gesammelt da du bereits die systeme administriert
hast weißt du genau worauf du achten muss bei linux schon bei windows gebe ich das offen
zu bei windows und oracle nicht und ich würde auch äußerst ungern windows server administrieren
müssen ja das ist blablabla das ist auch blablabla linux kopane das anzettel also checken wir
mal check check check naja je nachdem was ihr wissen wollt check check check moment
da war es noch mss ane hier hier naja was ihr auch immer da wissen wollt check check
check ähm wenn ihr wissen wollt bin ich der agilste typ der welt okr kostfunktional rufbereitschaft
der rufbereitschaft kommt auf die bezahlung an aber ja passt doch
ich finde das ist eine gute stellenanzeige marcel hängt alles von der bezahlung ab ich
finde das ist eine gute stellenanzeige ich finde auch diesen hinweis hier mit vorfeld
fragen und so ich finde das ist eine gute stellenanzeige es ist vollzeit passt halt
nicht aber trotzdem ich finde es nicht schlecht da stand auch was von remote dein team stellt
sich vor das team besteht aktuell aus 25 mitarbeitern mitarbeiterinnen offenbach haf die abi
goethe straße louis vitor store zahlt die kollektion barfick auf sponsor aber die goethe
straße ist in frankfurt aber offenbach ich bin geboren in offenbach ich würde damit
quasi in meine geburtstadt zurückkehren bin geboren im offenbacher stadtkranken nee offenbacher
heißt es stadtkrankenhaus keine ahnung ja die kernverantwortung von customer operation
ist die betreuung der cloud infrastruktur unserer kundinnen oh du musst regelmäßig
mit kunden telefonieren kritisch kopp das ist die abkürzung für customer operations
kopp ich warum stehen die alle so auf abkürzung mann kopp leistet für unsere kunden das management
und den betrieb von hochverfügbaren sicher und flexibel glottis mit individuellen plattform
servicemanager bei den im team betriebenen lösungen handelt sich in der regel nicht
um standardprodukte sondern individuelle infrastrukturen die von den kunden zugeschnitten
die auf den kunden zugeschnitten sind gut sonst bräuchte sie die auch nicht kritischer
hase na der ist ja im insie modus aktuell der kritische hase der macht den insie modus
die auf den kunden zugeschnitten sind somit stellt jedes neue projekt eine neue herausforderung
da ja das ding ist halt wenn ihr euch darum kümmert projekte sind nie abgeschlossen ihr
sagt ihr ihr betreibt das das bedeutet im endeffekt eine gewisse einheitlichkeit wäre
da schon wünschenswert weil wir sollten das sonst administrieren du hast 20 kunden
bei allem sieht es komplett anders aus das kann ja auch nicht sinn und zweck da sein
ich suche einen neuen job ja oder ich suche aktuell einfach ich will gucken was es gibt
je nachdem wie sich das home office technisch entwickelt bei mir auf der arbeit cross funkt
cross funktional evaluieren hyperweiser kontinuerisierung automatisierung backup und zukünftige technologien
gemeinsam fahren wir die technik konzeption in ok ich muss sagen ich finde die stelle
guck mal hier das das ist ja richtig ausführte ausführlich ausführlich ok ich muss sagen
ich habe mich ganz kurz verlesen bei dem namen aber ich werde es jetzt nicht sagen weil cringe
du möchtest wissen wie der bewerbungsprozess bei uns abläuft von deiner bewerbung möchte
wir dir zu viele fragen ok also ein reich ein reichung deiner bewerbung eingangsbestätigung
sichtung deiner unterlagen telefoninterview vorstellungsgespräch probe tag vorstellungs
na gut wenn es sein muss ok das ist halt das ist ja auch schon wieder alter ok telefoninterview
verstehe ich vorstellungsgespräch logisch probe tag finde ich nicht schlecht finde ich
auch gut aber nachdem du den scheiß durch hast noch mal hinten drauf vorstellungsgespräch
also du hast quasi schon mehr oder weniger näher eineinhalb tage investiert bei denen
und dann sagt die geschäftsführung vielleicht auch ne oder wir passen nicht zusammen also
wenn man wenn man sagt man mal diese zwei dinger hier verbinden würde ok wo ist eigentlich
die vierte wo ist eigentlich viertens aber ja gut ich mein ich denke das geht das geht
in ordnung ich mein letztendlich die stellen die leute ein wenn die diese wenn sie diese
vorstellungen haben und man sich drauf bewirbt da muss man halt das mitmachen weil sonst
lässt was halt bleiben ich finde das ich finde das gar nicht so bild aber ich finde es bisschen
doof dass das halt extra ist ich mein probe tag und danach zur geschäftsführung das ist
doch der cloud engineer oder es ist nicht der cloud engineer ein jetzt da sehen wir system
administrator vorstellungsgespräch geschäftsführung wie groß ist in der laden ok unterzeichnung
deines arbeitsvertrages pre boarding on boarding roadmap einarbeitung ja es ist gut dass es
sowas gibt ich ich persönlich würde zur einarbeitung die probetag finde ich nicht blöd probetag
finde ich gut für mich finde ich probetag gut weil ganz im ernst die können dir viel
erzählen wenn der tag lang ist ich will nicht unterschreiben bevor ich den laden nicht
gesehen habe allerdings sollte hier hier vor so ungefähr schon mal klar sein was es für
kole gibt ob du dann überhaupt weiter also eigentlich sollte das hier schon ungefähr
klar sein ob sich das lohnt weiter zu machen übrigens was ich bei einarbeitung persönlich
bevorzugen würde anstatt ich meine es ist gut dass es eine roadmap gibt dass es eine
liste mit ansprechpartnern gibt und so ist alles gut das fehlt bei uns wo ich aktuell
arbeite ein bisschen für neue leute aber unbezahlter probetag nee dass du nicht mal
nicht sagen dass der unbezahlt ist das muss nicht zwangsläufig unbezahlt sein auf der
anderen seite wirklich was sinnvolles arbeiten tust du da ja auch nicht so und was soll ich
sagen mir persönlich ist es ehrlich gesagt am liebsten wisst ihr wie ich die einarbeitung
am besten mag in dem die einarbeitung einfach stattfindet in form von es gibt was weiß
ich es ist team runde diese und diese themen müssen gemacht werden ich sage ich nehme
thema a und kümmere mich drum und wenn ich nicht weiterkomme brauche ich einen ansprechpartner
dem den ich fragen kann wie das hier läuft das ist die einarbeitung die mir am liebsten
ist ich habe keinen bock auf eine woche lang durch die firma geführt werden dann dort
irgendwas präsentiert bekommen dann hier und da und hast du nicht gesehen ich will
dahin anfangen zu arbeiten mir ein problem schnappen und technik machen und ich hätte
gerne einen ansprechpartner den man fragen kann wenn ich mit dem mit dem unternehmen
noch nicht klarkomme was sie da machen das ist das ist die liebste einarbeitung bei mir
ist wenn ich einfach was machen kann
meine ansprechpartnerin aus der personalabteilung okay da gibt es anscheinend nur medels
im detail also ganz im ernst zumindest gehalt grob sollte sollte mal hier im vorfeld aber
spätestens in diesen zwei schon halbwegs klar sein weil ganz eigentlich zumindest mal
so grob die die die rahmen bedingungen ja die müssen eigentlich hier schon klar sein
weil ganz im ernst ich mache noch nicht dass das und das bevor ich weiß was ich so ungefähr
erwarten kann und ob sich unsere vorstellungen decken 420 viewer 420 viewer ja richtig richtig
mit connect mäßig gibt mir alle euer geld für den keks nft ne also das muss klar sein
vorher guck mal ob da irgendwas mit gehalt vorher schon drin steht ne also gehalt machen
erst hier ganz im ernst einstiegsdatum das sollte alles schon direkt am anfang ein bisschen
zur sprache kommen aber das wird das würde ich einfach also wenn ich das machen würde
man glaube ich würde mich da bewerben ich finde es ja nicht schlecht ja das würde ich
dann schon abklopfen soweit weil es hat ja keinen sinn wenn man erst das alles durch
gemacht hat und dann da feststellt schau mal die defops stelle an habt ihr das im chat
gepostet das da cloud engineer
gütersloh ja solange ich remote arbeiten kann soll mir das recht sein flio das steht
für individuelle und komplexe hosting projekte flio ok linux poc virtualisierung poc infraschut
defops poc dabei erstellst du in enger zusammenarbeit mit dem sales sales sowohl technische konzeption
für neue projekte kubernetes open stack ist irgendwie bei der telekom ist open stack
auch so beliebt das ja gut ticketsystem projekt miete gut das ist halt kommst du da links
wo dran vorbei ok mehrjährige erfahrung in der konzeption entwicklung cloud nativer
anwendung platform wo ich muss ehrlich sagen also als cloud engineer habe ich keine mehrjährige
erfahrung mit der entwicklung cloud nativer anwendung und platform ich bin ja kein software
entwickler wie viele jahre ist mehrjähriger zwei defops er spars sind für dich nicht
nur basswörter sondern gelebte praxis ja doch es sind basswörter aber im cloud umfeld
benutzt sie also das was dahinter steckt eigentlich mehr oder weniger jeder weil das das ist was
cloud ausmacht defops weniger aber infrastructure as service und platform as a service ich bin
ja eh dafür dass mal irgendjemand soft service as a service macht so als wildcard also du
kannst ja die meisten cloud infrastruktur nicht anders benutzen ja entweder machst du dir in der
cloud eine vm dann ist es infrastructure as service also wenn du jetzt beispielsweise nach
azure gehst dort eine vm anlegt und dennungs drauf installiert installiert dann ist es
infrastructure as service quasi wenn du dir irgendwelche fertigen sachen von asia oder
von von irgendeiner anderen cloud platform irgendwas fertiges verwendet zum beispiel
man an starten bank dann ist es platform as a service du kannst cloud sachen gar nicht
anders als platform as a service oder infrastructure as a service verwenden kennst du der f0 as a
service ja du verfügst über ein tiefes know-how im bereich container und cloud platform was ist
tiefes know-how also ich würde sagen in anderen bereichen habe ich mehr know-how also gerade in
diesem bereich kenne ich mich deutlich besser aus als was kubernetes administration angeht
davon habe ich plan davon habe ich plan davon habe ich richt davon habe ich plan ansible kenne
ich mich aus tower ist das ansible frontend geht obs es gibt nichts was geht obs heißt also das
ist irgendwie so ein eine wortschöpfung und und umschreibt irgendwie so platform infrastructure
es code und und geht workflows also es also es gibt kein produkt das geht obs heißt das ist
so ein bisschen so wie wenn die leute sagen wir sind agil echt openshift geht obs ist ein
service der genauso verkauft wird das ist dann openshift geht obs operator ist vielleicht meinen
sie das ja operator sdk ich habe keine ahnung was das ist helm kenne ich aber ich habe keine ahnung
was opera leute was ist operator versuchen danach was ist operator sdk ich habe keine ahnung ist
saumäßig beliebt ist saumäßig beliebt hat 5000 sonst war es sterne auf github
das ist damit kann ich quasi dafür sorgen dass meine anwendung besser in kubernetes laufen also
sprich ja was ist das denn was kann ich mir darunter vorstellen dass ich zum beispiel
ordentliche health checks habe dass ich meine applikationen ordentlich verhält beim switch
vom eingangslot balancer oder oder was oder was mache ich damit
das da kann ich nichts mit anfangen vielleicht nicht die richtige stelle für mich
operators interpretieren deine cdrs ich weiß mit aaron krach was cdrs sind das sind irgendwelche
custom definitionen oder sowas für kubernetes objekte aber was ich habe keine ahnung was es
macht du machst einfach import und dann bist du agil easy habe ich da noch blockchain weil
ohne blockchain kann ich mein kubernetes cluster nicht betreiben sollte klar sein ich hoffe ihr
betreibt euren kubernetes cluster nicht ohne blockchain er nicht nicht geht ja nicht
blockchain auf war etcd das wäre es ja etcd habe ich letztens erst abgeschaltet bei uns auf der
arbeit wir hatten noch irgendein uralt etcd das ist so key value store cluster bei uns rumsteht
da habe ich in unserer wartungsarbeiten runde angekündigt ich schalte den etcd cluster aus
hat keinen interessiert habe ich den etcd cluster ausgeschaltet und wisst ihr was war
irgendeiner sagte jetzt laufen aber meine automatischen jobs nicht mehr richtig woran
könnte das denn liegen ja und hatten sie noch irgendwelche etc ctl gett aufrufe auf keys die
sich seit fünf jahren nicht mehr geändert haben oder so ne das geht nicht ohne blockchain wobei
man könnte ja jetzt sagen und geht ist eine blockchain change my mind chat geht ist eine
blockchain ok gucken wir mal weiter prometheus kibana grafana influx db warum stehen die alle
so da drauf messaging infra kafka alle das ist richtiger pfeiffer kram da brauchst du allein
schon mindestens ein team aus fünf über 140 eq plus leute dass du kafka sachen überhaupt
installiert bekommst nie geht erlaubt nicht das rewriting der history geht erlaubt es das
überschreiben der history aber nicht das rewriting der history also kannst nicht die history
austauschen und danach ist es quasi so als wäre vorher nichts nix als wäre nichts gewesen also
wenn du die gett history änderst umschreibst dann ist die komplette history ab diesem kommet
anders laut balance engine nix nee hast du nicht verpasst wir haben noch ein paar sefs net ab ok
das wird teuer das wird überall wo net ab drauf stehen können voraus ging es mit teuer das habe
ich auch schon mal gehört da bin ich mir nicht so sicher ich glaube nicht dass das das richtige
ist für mich die sind mir zu super agil im cloud native umfeld mit kubernetes und das alles ohne
blockchain low level hardware stellen ich suche ja stellen die ich theoretisch auch machen will low
level hardware ich meine ich glaube dass ich in esp 32 mit monitor und darauf ein anzeigen lassen
kann reicht nicht ganz als hardware entwege als hardware nahe entwickler selbst in kuba nee das
stimmt das kann sein ja das wie gesagt ich habe das bei uns auf der arbeit auch schon mal ist
man auch schon mal in die finger gekommen bewerben ich glaube nicht dass das das richtige für mich
ist ehrlich gesagt ich meine remote ist es ja wieso arbeitest du da oder wie oder warum bist
du jetzt überhaupt darauf gekommen max hat mehr viewer als aporette und das war das bei
it stellen anzeigen überlegt euch mal wenn ich jetzt noch den insi modus aktivieren würde dann
wird es hier durch die decke gehen so das haben wir uns schon angeguckt
modern c plus wir haben doch letztens modern c plus plus gemacht mit web assembly das war
appeals champ genug c plus plus 23 ist doch jetzt sogar schon angesagt ich habe letztens
irgendein vortrag gehört über c plus plus 23 und bin wieder vom glauben abgefallen was für ein bullshit
alles drinne ist die shopwär anzeige wo welche habe ich die schon auf hier ok
der fox engineer also was mache ich in standhaltung überwachen und fehlerbehebung
von continues integration continues delivery pipelines ja gut das war eher c was du gemacht
das was soll denn das heißen die datei endung war eindeutig cpp jetzt will er uns erzählen
dass das c war kann überhaupt nicht sein datei endung lügen nicht so ich meine nur weil ich
printf verwendet habe o patrick weil er wahrscheinlich macht er es richtig der entwickelt c plus plus zum
größten teil in c deswegen weiß er das nicht sei ich guter mann wahrscheinlich der weiß auf was
er sich besser nicht einlassen sollte also aufrecht erhaltung und verbessern unsere automatisierten
freigabe prozesse aha mentoring ja ok alles klar das ist jetzt recht unspezifisch ehrlich
gesagt erfahrung mit linux und keine kontinuerisierung das habe ich relativ viel also wenn 14 jahre ausreichen
linux und ja container krempel weiß gar nicht wie lang gibt es denn den graben schon bestimmt
fünf jahre ich denke das ist so im maximalen bereich des möglichen ja was ich an erfahrung
habe gerade im linux umfeld also du wirst du wirst nicht viel mehr leute finden die 14 jahre linux
erfahrung haben kenntnisse in den bereichen kontinuierliche liefung ach hier schreiben wir
jetzt auf deutsch ok bereitstellung in integration erfahrung mit den betriebs ja die mürgen
gibt es finde ich gut in letzter zeit war es eher so dass ich gedacht habe die stehen alle irgendwie
mehr auf bitt bucket aber ich könnte mir vorstellen dadurch dass du mittlerweile in git lab relativ gut
eigene definition machen kannst was kontinuous integration angeht die haben ja mittlerweile
support für git lab ci mit jammel konfig und sowas deswegen ist das recht beliebt git lab
ci sagt etwas ich muss dir ehrlich sagen ich habe git lab ci verwendet da war das ganz neu
und das war unbenutzbar ich habe git lab jahre lang bei uns administriert ja aber von git lab ci
habe ich jetzt so hands-on wenig plan nicht dass du trotz trau ich mir dazu mich 0, nix da drin
einzuarbeiten ich meine so der große unterschied wird es jetzt nicht sein
ich mag jenkins wirklich leute jenkins ist zwar also jenkins haftet halt sehr an dass es eine
oldschool fette java anwendung ist und ja das ist auch so ich meine allein schon guckt euch
mal das jenkins front an das sieht aus wie von 1995 das sieht moment das sieht mittlerweile
nicht das hier meine ich das hier meine ich also das sieht schon nicht gerade cloud native bleeding
edge web 3.0 aus aber trotzdem ich mag jenkins jenkins ist einfach das flexibelste das flexibelste
system in dieser richtung und ich hatte damals als das wie gesagt noch vor zeiten wo das alles
noch nicht mal defops hieß hatte ich schon uns jenkins aufgesetzt und wir haben automatische
tests über den jenkins gemacht das war mir da waren wir tatsächlich mal zu dieser zeit weit
voraus unserer zeit mittlerweile nicht mehr mittlerweile ist es eher so dass wir in unserer
zeit dort wo ich gerade aber hinterher rennen weil sehr merkwürdige entscheidungen getroffen werden
also ich habe ich habe damals und damals ist wirklich schon lange her habe ich auch schon
pipelines im jenkins verwendet und das war nicht irgendwie java oder sonst wie das sah so sah das
nicht aus also es kommt ehrlich gesagt noch am ehesten das hin wie das aussah aber so sah es
auch nicht aus nee ist egal aber ich mag jenkins ich finde jenkins ist einfach das flexibelste
system man kann das verwenden als bildserver das ist ja mal so das ding wo das ursprünglich
eigentlich herkommt ja jenkins kommt aus einer zeit noch da hat keiner continues integration
continues delivery gesagt hat man gesagt ich verwende jenkins quasi als bildserver oder als
kiste die nach einem push irgendwelche tests durchführen irgendwelche sachen baut damals hat
noch keiner continues integration continues delivery hatzen hieß das früher ja aber das
jenkins logo sieht halt auch aus wie 1995 es gibt aber für jenkins ein chuck norris plugin
das ist das aller das ist das allerwichtigste das chuck norris plugin für jenkins
also ganz enorm wichtiges plugin also ich mag jenkins ganz ehrlich was flexibilität
angeht und wenn man was haben will was man bei sich lokal läuft laufen lässt finde ich
ist jenkins wirklich nice hast du solution auf discord also ja und ja habe ich irgendwo
ich habe sogar noch seine handy nummer irgendwo das weiß er doch bestimmt schon dass sein
kanal geknackt ist oder das da wartet er bestimmt nicht darauf dass ich das jetzt irgendwie
ihm sage der ist doch sogar on ist er on wie sieht es auf twitter aus auf twitch twitch
twitch x solution
nee das ist nicht das weiß der bestimmt schon und auf twitter das weiß der garantiert schon
der don raven
wieder nix mehr gepostet acht hier hier ist er ok keine ahnung keine ahnung das weiß
der bestimmt schon ich rufe jetzt nicht random an ich kann ich kann jetzt schlecht jemand
bei dem ich seit über einem jahr oder oder noch länger kein kontakt mehr richtig hatte
sagen so nach dem oder alter was geht dein kanal ist gehackt wobei doch können ich machen
aber der weiß das bestimmt schon
nie
ich mal genau ich glaube da reicht sein budget nicht für oder ich weiß ich
vielleicht ist er mittlerweile so dick im business dass er millionen macht dann
schon dank dann kümmere ich mich um seine security
ihr abo rett im insie modus ist glaube ich nicht der beste arbeitgeber aktuell
so das finde ich cool dass die hier die bewehrt dass die anderen auch schon den
bewerbungsprozess reingeschrieben haben
ja ok ist bisschen wenig details drin aber nicht verkehrt ja wie sieht es hier
mit remote aus und mit homeoffice seht ihr da irgendwie was dazu flexible
arbeitszeiten heißt ja nix
seht ihr irgendwas was homeoffice super arbeitsplatz mobiles arbeiten
ah ja ok nice bei ich mir mal ist so lustig dass du die alle damals kann es
auch so ja tatsächlich ich habe halt nichts mehr mit den leuten zu tun das
sind auch komplett andere menschen mittlerweile glaube ich und kennen ist
bei vielen auch zu viel gesagt war halt call of duty ich ich gebe dir header
one-on-one rast zeiten
naja das würde ich das würde das muss also wenn ich irgendwo was wenn ich
wo neues hingehen und die sagen homeoffice ist erlaubt dann will ich
dass es im arbeitsvertrag drin steht ich habe nämlich keinen bock dass es so
läuft wie bei meinem jetzigen arbeitgeber so nach dem motto ja ja wir sind super
modern und homeoffice und sonst wie und dann ach nee doch kein bock mehr
würde es gleich war so noch spielen
ich habe vor sonn relativ häufig gespielt als es neu war wochen paar
wochen lang sogar zwei drei monate lang sogar aber da hatte ich irgendwie kein
bock mehr
ich habe eine richtig gute glaube ich zumindest ich glaube ich habe eine
richtig gute spiele zu win ratio das liegt aber daran weil ich krass
gecarriert wurde von gut also moment haben wir sonst noch irgendwas
chat ihr habt doch noch mehr geschickt
ihr wer seid das hatten wir gerade schon oder das das haben wir auch noch
wenn man das ja komplett in englisch we are all sitting in one boat
aber was gibt man rechne ab chat chat seid ihr das chat seid ihr das der
krypto meiner ist im hintergrund aktiv vier guckt mal
was ist hier mit den chrome tabs los
desktop ich muss mal der desktop leute also ich kann euch sagen wie man
reproduzierbar low iq leute erkennt low iq leute erkennt man reproduzierbar
daran dass sie nicht verstehen dass der desktop ein ganz normaler ordner ist
der desktop ist nichts besonderes der desktop ist ein ganz normaler ordner und
ich verwende den als normalen ordner
ja bitcoin meiner im java script suzzi
ernsthaft suzzi
alter mein browser ist mega am abscheißen gerade
das waren die tabs wohl alles klar die amazon tabs die amazon tabs war uns alles klar ok
nice gg eats gefunden amazon krypto meiner du wolltest doch was mit
infrastructure nicht zwangsläufig was mit infrastructure was im defops
bereich ich muss nicht zwangsläufig cloud defops engineer das ist mal für
den den kram was wollen die denn hier bla bla bla bla das ist mir zu zu
advanced englisch ich kann das ohne probleme lesen das ist nicht schwierig
aber es ist mir zu englisch als als hauptsprache oder
very gut knowledge ich habe keine very gut knowledge ich habe ok knowledge soweit dass
ich mit irgendwelchen englisch englischsprachigen leuten sachen
zusammen installieren kann aber es nicht so dass ich hier auf native speaker
niveau dass das raushaue als jemand da schon mercedes software gesehen hat an
rennen echt so schlimm was suchen die denn
zeigt mal her wir bauen keine autos sondern gestalten die digitale zukunft
der mobilität immer dieses ultra dick auch ich das ist ein auto hersteller wo
ist denn das problem zu sagen ja es ist ein auto hersteller das ist ungefähr so
wie wenn sie bei mir auf der arbeit erzählen ja hier verkaufen versicherungen
oder ich sage immer versicherungen weil das ist das was im ausendienst
hauptsächlich gemacht wird obwohl wir eine bank sind aber aus den verkauf viel
versicherungen wir verkaufen versicherungen wir verkaufen keine
versicherungen wir machen menschen glücklich das ist auch so zeug was
bescheuert wäre
wir machen keine menschen glücklich werden wir nehmen ihr geld und fügen es
unserem geld hinzu wir suchen nach einem agilen cloud dev ops engineer für die
entwicklung von ganzheitlichen software sie umdruckt du brennst für modernste
klau ich glaube dass ich mit meinem auto instant disqualifiziert bin da zu
arbeiten ihr wisst mein auto ist weder ein
mercedes noch irgendwie ein sonderlich krasses auto im vergleich zu dem was
man sich heute unter coolen autos vorstellt aber er ist agil du brennst
für moderne schon wieder einer wo man brennen soll du brennst für moderne
klaut native architektur und patterns für IT-produkte der marke moment was
der satz ergibt keinen sinn
ja das ist durchschnittsgehalt in ulm das heißt nicht dass es ist dort dort
gibt du brennst für moderne klaut native architektur und soweit soweit ergibt
der satz noch sinn und patterns für IT-produkte der marke mercedes brenn
was weiß ich denn was ihr für patterns und ich weiß noch nicht mal was ihr
überhaupt für produkte habt wie kann ich denn dafür brennen ich weiß
noch nicht mal was ihr was ihr habt
außerdem e-autos wenn die brennen ist ganz schlecht
infrastructure es kohlt endlich mal einer jeder die coolen buzzwords
rausholt das habe ich extra in mein zeugnis
reinschreiben lassen infrastructure es kohlt und das brauche muss buzzwords muss
das sein und auch klinik natürlich leute ich bin der geilste klinik oder seht ihr
beispielsweise moment ich habe doch mal so in so
den ich habe aber absichtlich richtigen müll gepusht
wo war denn das war das war frisi null zwar das erste projekt was ich glaube ich
gepusht habe damals dachte ich sogar ich mache tests
keck weight screenshot tool ihr clean clean code achtung
keine ahnung ich habe irgendwo was absichtlich richtig ekliges gepostet
das wollte ich euch jetzt zeigen im punkto clean code aber wer clean code
sehen will muss ich mein 10 plus plus was am stream angucken
cleanerer code geht nicht
deffops ccd agiles arbeit liegt ihr im blut da oben brenne ich da unten ist
irgendwas im blut drinnen dich interessieren neueste täte das stimmt
tatsächlich ja mich interessieren so gut wie alle
ganz nein das stimmt nicht so gut also mich interessieren viele alle ist
übertrieben mich interessieren viele trends wir gucken uns neue frameworks an
wir probieren die neuesten sachen hier im stream aus also ich bin schon dass ich
da relativ breit gelagerte interesse noch wie gesagt von cloud bis micro
controller entwicklung bis irgendwelche neuen front-end back-end frameworks was
im lielungsbereich so passiert sieht man ja auch immer muss eins muss wenn man
mal zugeben chat ich weiß guck mal hier wenn ich hier durchgucke die meisten von
euch kenne ich hier vom namen her ihr müsst auch eins zugucken ihr müsst auch
eins zugeben wie gesagt ich sage jetzt weil ich euch hier öfters auch vom namen
her sehe es ist doch was content it content technisch angeht machen wir wir
haben alles schon mal irgendwie angerissen hier im stream oder ich mein
von windows wir haben sogar windows server ich bin halb durchgedreht bei
linux windows cobalt front-end back-end microcontroller c-sharp c plus plus go
alles
assembler hatten wir auch schon ja ich glaube merkel server hatten wir noch
nicht neue neuere linux distribution kontinuerisierung automatisierung
entzippel contain letztes haben wir auf die stelle noch ein paar docker container gebaut
raspberry pie geschichten rumbasteln elektronik mäßig wlan sachen
netzwerkhardware also da kann sich echt nicht beschweren das ist ja wirklich
alles also wir haben alles irgendwie schon gemacht also themengebiete
angerissen alles
deine freizeit ist uns wichtig ja wie sieht es mit home office aus
gar nicht
hat irgendjemand was von remote gelesen
mit mobiles arbeiten gab es da nichts ohne home office kommt es erschreckt
mich nicht so kommt es für mich nicht in frage da kann ich auch bleiben wo ich
aktuelle echt wo mobil
mobil arbeiten möglichkeit der teilzeit einfache wieder ein klinik oder ok dann
ist doch nicht schlecht
es ist in ulm ja gut wenn das remote ist dann interessiert mich nicht ob das in
ulm ist zumal ich ulm ehrlich leute ich habe gehofft ich muss nie wieder nach
ulm aber ich bin jetzt zeitlang mal nach ulm gefahren öfters job technisch und ich
hatte mal ein hotel am münster und da ist mir aufgefallen dass diese kacke
kirche auch nachts klingelt kannst du überhaupt nicht schlafen um alle um ist
keine stadt die mir gefällt
willst du willst du in der behörde arbeiten alles remote only die arbeitest
du in der behörde ich dachte du arbeitest bei diesem defops laden wo du
vorher was geschickt hast du klangst da so wahnsinnig überzeugt von
aber schickt schickt mal rüber schickt schickt mal ich bin jetzt nicht
wahnsinnig scharf drauf bei der behörde zu arbeiten aber mir ist es eigentlich
egal so lange home office und die bezahlung stimmt und die täte der
tätigkeitsbereich data ops engineer ne so was will ich nicht das nicht das
nichts das nichts das glaube ich das richtige für mich du kannst alle meine
gehen mal auf meinen moment du kannst auf mein profil gehen und da steht die
email adresse kommt man du kannst hier drauf klicken about oder hast du die
email adresse warum willst du den job wechsel ich will den job wechseln weil
sie sich bei uns überlegt haben die leute sollen wieder 50 prozent ins büro
kommen ich habe einfach keinen bock mehrfach die woche mit der bahn zu
fahren zumal ich ja selbst nur 40 also nur vier tage arbeit das heißt ich fahre
zwei tage ich bin zwei tage da und zwei tage weg das heißt sind 50 prozent da
habe ich überhaupt kein bock drauf und ich sehe es bei uns in zukunft eher so
dass es sich noch negativer entwickelt die probieren es jetzt aus mit zwei tagen
und wenn die leute das mitmachen sind es bald drei tage
welche gehals range stellst du dir vor da müsste ich erst mal ausrechnen was
ich aktuell verdiene also ich habe vor einer ganzen weile irgendwas
bisschen über 70.000 euro verdient und es gab jetzt in letzter zeit einige
prozente mehr geld und auch mehr bonus
und noch mal was extra weil ich jetzt zehn jahre dabei bin cacquait ich würde
mal sagen aktuell ist es eher ich weiß es gar nicht 80.000 oder so
irgendwie in dem dreh hochgerechnet auf fünf hochgerechnet auf vollzeit stelle
natürlich ja hochgerechnet auf vollzeit stelle da musste er noch mal
einen tag von abziehen ich rechne es immer hoch auf auf 40
stunden weil ansonsten kann es nicht richtig vergleichen ich denke mal
irgendwas um 80.000 werde ich aktuell verdienen so das schöne ist daran dass
es mit einem tarifvertrag ist das heißt es gibt automatisch was mehr und ich
würde mal anpeilen schon was um die 100k nach oben natürlich offen wenn ich den
job wechsle das ist nämlich meine aktuellen zeit was
inflation angeht und dass es halt auch für die nächsten paar jahre irgendwie
ein ordentliches ordentliches gehalt ist zumal ich eh weniger bekomme weil ich
teilzeit arbeite ja also das peile ich auch an das was du hier schreibst
ja das habe ich bei uns auch versucht die letzten jahre über manchmal hat es
geklappt manchmal nicht
es kommt drauf an es kommt darauf an was du machst
ja mal gucken mal gucken ich meine ohne scheiß leute ich habe überhaupt kein
problem damit wenn es ein bisschen weniger ist und dafür ich mich da
wohlfühle und das thema homeoffice entsprechend gehandhabt wird ich würde
auch weniger nehmen ganz ehrlich wenn der laden gut ist ab wann ist man senior
def ab dann wenn es auf deinem titel steht wenn es auf deinem schild steht
bis zu sehen wir darf
kann man nicht dran festmachen an irgendwas wenn du den titel senior hast
dann bist du senior
das kommt auf die wie gesagt das kommt auf die region an
aber leute ich bin ziemlich im arsch ich glaube ich gehe jetzt auf ich kann mir
immer überlegen nicht mehr nachdenken und ich war nicht
mal vorlesen und reicht jetzt
was war noch mal deine kern ko ich habe eigentlich keinen bock noch mal alles zu
erzählen aber aktuell arbeite ich also ok ich ich ich erzähle es noch mal kurz
also aktuell bin ich bei einer bank in frankfurt im ich nenne es mal defops
bereich weil ich dort mit diese sachen was heute unter defops und continuous
integration continuous delivery läuft damals mit eingeführt habt zu zeiten
wo das doch nicht defops hieß deswegen heißt unsere abteilung auch nicht
irgendwie was mit mit defops oder sonst was sondern wir heißen überlege gerade
wie wir heißen ich glaube infrastruktur infrastruktur service oder so was
ach keine ahnung genau und oder ich kann ich über nachdenken keine ahnung
so lang gestreamt
stimmt ich habe ein video ich habe ein video drüber gemacht ich habe ein video
drüber gemacht ich habe es gibt verschiedene clips wo ich erkläre was
ich auf der arbeit mache ja also ich kenne mich ich kenne mich gut aus ich
kenne mich ich sagte dass ich sagte einfach mal von was ich von was ich
irgendwie ein bisschen von was ich irgendwie planen hab also unabhängig von
dem zeug was was wir im stream machen also ich kenne mich ziemlich gut aus in
sagen wir in diesem ganz defops sektor von git angefangen von git als
versionsverwaltung ich habe damals git hooks gebastelt wo das noch komplette
magic war die leute sich gefragt haben wie warum lehnt unser repo auf einmal
irgendwelche kommets ab geht geht ab mit parket geht lab habe ich damals
eingeführt bei uns jenkins mit als bildserver damals hat noch keiner
continuous integration continuous delivery gesagt ccd mehr oder weniger
mache ich gerade das infrastruktur s code und schrägstrich konfig management für
ungefähr 3000 linux systeme bin ich hier verantwortlich aktuell und
ja was was infrastruktur konfig management angeht ansippe puppet bash
ruby groovy python scripting mit linux kenne ich mich auch recht gut aus von
rettet ubuntu bis was hoch verfügbar keine ausfallssicherheit angeht
kontinuerisierung skalierung ich kann tatsächlich auch ganz gut sie scharpen
dort net entwickeln auch wenn ich mich nicht als hauptberuflichen programmierer
sehen will in zukunft go kann ich ganz gut javascript und die werde lachen ich
habe sogar relativ viel technische dokumentation geschrieben die letzten
jahre über aber das will ich nicht dass es mein job wird
ja reicht das mehr kann ich mir gerade nicht aus dem ermitt schütteln und
falls du eine gute idee hast falls du eine gute idee hast immer immer her damit
also ich denke ich habe auch mit den ein oder anderen streams hier für manche
leute zugucken denke ich durchaus meine kompetenz in vielen bereichen schon
unter beweis gestellt dass es nicht komplett heiße luft ist die ich erzähle
ich erzähle viel heiße luft das gebe ich zu aber von einem großteil der heißen
luft habe ich sogar ahnung
hast post ok ich gucke mir es morgen an ich gucke mal ich gucke mal rein ich
gucke mal rein ob noch mehr leute was geschrieben haben das interessiert mich
jetzt einfach ich gucke mal rein ich hoffe der keylogger hängt an der e-mail
oder keylogger ist raus
bitte nicht ich zeige es nicht öffentlich ne ne keine sorge ich zeige
es nicht öffentlich ich gucke nur mal in die e-mail rein mache ich nicht trust
me ich bin profit welche davon bist du bist bist du fängt ein vorname mit m an
ja ok ok dann bist du das hier gucke ich mir morgen an
opera gx möchte mal wieder werbung machen alter die können sich auch nicht
überlegen das war aber echt keine absicht ja das
war komplett gebaited dass auf einmal da unten der echte name stand
ich programmiere nicht hauptberuflich ich programmiere viele im stream und ich
programmiere gerne aber ich bin auch aktuell kein haupt hauptberuflicher
entwickler doch schick mal schick sarex schick je nachdem was es ist ich mein ich
bin da ich bin da offen für ich weiß nicht ob ich ob ich hauptberuflicher
entwickler wirklich werden möchte aber angucken tue ich mir alles also wenn ihr
irgendwas habt leute was ihr nicht öffentlich im chat posten wollt vielleicht
weil ihr da arbeitet oder so und denkt der maxer wird da gut passen
schickt einfach an meine email adresse habe ich ja gerade gezeigt
könnte hier auf verbaut gehen und dann steht hier meine business email schreibt
aber wenn es geht irgendwas mit irgendwie stelle oder so mit dem titel dass ich
weiß was es ist das lösche ich noch aus versehen weil ich denke es ist wieder
nord vpn das habe ich vor drei minuten erzählt
ich will jetzt nicht noch mal das alles runter beten ich wie gesagt ich würde
gerne im deffops bereich weitermachen das was ich jetzt auch aktuell mache
ansible puppet infrastructure as code repo management release management
continuous integration delivery kontinuierierung tool entwicklung
nein ich ziehe nicht um also für mich ist kommt es nur in frage wenn das 100
prozent remote ist wenn das in anderen städten ist also wenn ich wenn ich
zweimal im jahr nach münchen fahren muss ist das ok da komme ich mit klar aber
einmal die woche nach münchen fahren will ich nicht und oder berlin oder ihr
wisst wie ich das meine er und ich ziehe definitiv nicht um ich habe hier ein
eigenes haus ich ziehe garantiert nie um wenn es nicht anders geht ja habe ich
vor ich habe jetzt einen katter der das macht
machst du auch was mit datenbanken ich benutze ab und zu postgres und ich finde
postgres ist die poggers datenbank die es gibt die die meiste die größte
poggers datenbank die es gibt aber ich bin kein dba ne da habe ich zu wenig
plan von
was klaut ogu
ist mal gucken doch das ist die gleiche von der anderen
anzeige eben
ja ich sehe aber nichts in der richtung da gerade guck mal ist so nichts da ist
kein admin und kein system engineer oder sowas in der richtung drinnen doch hier
sowas
wir leben flexible arbeitsvertrag arbeitszeiten aber arbeitstag
ogot active directory monka es ist windows
hier habe ich plan von habe ich plan von habe ich plan von es ist windows da will
ich kein plan von haben habe ich plan von
linux ja linux kenne ich mich seit 15 jahren aus aber windows will ich nicht
support erfahrung monkers
nein mein aktueller chef schaut nicht zu aber mein bis vor paar tagen chef der
schaut nicht mehr zu denke ich aber der schaute vorhin zu den habe ich nämlich
vorhin im chat kurz gesehen aber ich habe nicht weiter darauf reagiert weil ich
ihn ich hier liegen möchte ja na gut fast vollständig remote zu arbeiten
heute ich sehe schon wir brauchen morgen noch mal ein stream in der richtung die
m jobs und das ist ja eine farb auswahl wobei das liegt wahrscheinlich na dies
ist ja auch nicht besser wer kommt auf die idee und meint helles grün und helle
weiße text ist
rettet ok suse muss nicht sein aber rettet da kenne ich mich aus mit wenn ich
ehrlich gesagt ubuntu lieber mag aber es geschmackssache cc ansible pappa check
beratung troubleshooting gemeinsam mit unseren produkt teams warum stehen die
alle so auf ich zinger ich zinger weiß gar nicht wie man das ausspricht scheint
scheint voll scheint total beliebt zu sein ich habe noch kein zappix gesehen bei
denen heute ich weiß dass es nagios ist aber ich dachte eigentlich zappix ist
verbreitet könnte sein weil ich zinger in deutscher laden ist zinger was kann
man das ausspricht kann das vielleicht weil die aus deutschland kommen
elastix deck pro meter ist check check check check check check
helle büro flaschen
wo steht das wo steht das mit remote aber ein letztes fast vollständig remote
zu haben jet guter hinweis auch immer die haben
github die m trocke riemark githabe kauen
formen haben die auch am start interessant scheint ja doch verbreitet zu
sein wir waren nicht die einzigen die das haben
lisa lovely interface verlinungs admins
kein screenshot von lisa ich dachte wir können lisa uns als screenshot
angucken so nach github sternen service landscape visualizer ja so was
bräuchte auf der arbeit auch ok da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten ob man
daraus so viel erkennen kann
na gut voll am open source kontributen dm hat es rauf hier wie es aussieht
ruby
so wie viel mühe gibst du dir so an deinem bewerbungs anschreiben ja wenn es
was ist was mir gefällt dann gebe ich mir da schon mühe dabei weil ansonsten kann
ich es auch gleich sein lassen so leute aber ich gehe jetzt ins bett
bis morgen wir sehen uns macht's gut